This is Jocko podcast number 96 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening
and we are going to roll right into some Q and a from I'm sure people have the
interwebs.
Yes.
Well or not actually of the interwebs there from everyday life through the inner
is where we receive questions.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yeah,
it's been a while right since the Q and a has been a while since Q and I.
That's cool.
All right,
well first question.
Recently at my job,
we got a new supervisor,
one who happens to be retired army.
After 20 years.
He and I had a pretty heavy running two which resulted in getting HR involved.
The end result was that I would not be written up for what he claimed I was
doing.
He tried to make an example out of me almost as soon as he got here.
Assuming I was easy to eat.
He assumed I was an easy target anyways to the point.
Even though he and I had a falling out,
I'd still like to see the guy succeed at his job and become a great leader.
After listening to your podcast over the last month,
I'm making an effort to improve our relationship at this job instead of just
avoiding the men I've raced.
I've recently purchased your book extreme ownership.
How would you suggest are present this book to my new supervisor and a read or
to read without him feeling as if I'm belittling him as to say he needs work on
his leadership.
I think he could benefit from it greatly.
Good question.
Yeah,
it's actually a question I've answered on here before.
Bottle answered again because I even learned when I repeat.
Sure.
This is my latest version of what I tell people when they're in the situation.
Yeah.
Updated version because you get better at things and you figure out better ways
to overcome challenges,
especially when you're presented with the same challenge over and over again,
which I kind of am.
Yeah,
man.
Some challenges like this one,
so here's what,
here's what you do.
You give it to him and you say,
hey,
boss,
or hey person.
Hey,
I got this book and I'm trying to really emulate the principles that are in this
book.
It really hit me and I was wondering if I could ask you a favor,
if you could just look through this book,
kind of see what the principles are and then if you see me falling out align
with the principles of that are in this book,
let me know so I can fix them.
Basic things like if I'm not taking ownership of problems,
if I'm,
if I'm not keeping things simple,
if I'm not supporting other people around me covering and moving for them,
just let me know.
That's all I'm asking because I'm,
I'm really trying to do a better job.
Could you do that for me?
So then the person says,
well,
yeah,
okay,
fine.
You know,
and then they read the book and when they read the book,
sure there's a chance that there'll be thinking like,
oh,
this book is about everyone else and it's not about me.
Right,
right.
That's possible.
There is also a chance of a higher chance that they read the book and go,
Oof,
I make a lot of excuses and I blame other people all the time.
I'm probably not doing a great job as a leader and that might be subconscious.
I see that sometimes now where people are subconsciously making adjustments
because they don't want to admit that they're the person that's,
that,
that the problem.
They don't want to admit that they're the problem.
So they make these little adjustments kind of subconsciously.
And other people will tell me that the boss is like changing.
Oh yeah,
they're,
they're changing their game.
They won't admit it,
but they are changing their game.
So that's what you hope for is that they do,
they go through that trance,
that transformation from,
you know,
not taking ownership and treating people bad and not trying to build
relationships and all that stuff that makes them into a bad leader in to taking
ownership,
building relationships,
covering,
moving,
keeping things simple,
all the stuff that makes you a good leader.
That's what the hope is.
Now
there's also a chance that this person is going gonna hold a grudge,
right?
We,
we,
we got to deal with that.
And I'll tell you,
I was recently talking to someone that had stepped on the toes of another
business,
another division inside their business,
another sales division.
And you know,
salespeople are sort of known for being protective and aggressive look
protective of their territory.
Well this guy kind of stepped into their territory a little bit,
cause some bad,
bad vibes,
giant rift,
and he's like,
you don't,
what should I do?
You know why I feel like all this animosity now,
and it's one of those times where I just said to myself,
well,
what would I actually do if I was in that situation?
How would I try and get this problem solved?
Well,
what I would do is walk up to the person who I stepped into their territory and
cause problems and I'd say,
Hey,
hey,
I wanted to tell you I've,
I totally was out of line when I stepped into your territory that that was
completely my fault.
And you know,
I was just got target fixation,
which is bad.
I didn't talk to you,
I stepped into your world,
which is bad and I left a disaster.
And I,
I'm sorry.
That's that all that stuff,
everything that I just said,
all my fault and I want to let you know that I completely recognize it.
And number one,
anything I can do to try and redeem that and make it up and make you realize
that and anything I can do to support and help you move forward.
I,
I don't,
I will not let that happen again.
I just want to let you know that.
So boom,
just step up,
be humble,
apologize and say,
Hey,
can you,
what can I do to help you?
What can I do to support you?
That's where I would go with these,
with this question.
And then a sort of,
uh,
an addition to that question.
It's kind,
Kinda like,
uh,
you know,
when you,
when you give your both the book,
right?
It'd be like,
Hey,
this is what I'm doing.
Is that kind of like when you,
when you get,
you know,
like if somebody has a bad,
bad breath and then you put in gum,
you know,
you eat some gummies or hey,
you want some gum?
Yeah.
That's very similar.
You just break out the gum,
you know,
I was like to do this,
just to make sure I was like to have a piece of gum just to make sure you know a
lot of fun.
Oh you want one?
Yeah,
you could have,
you might want to take to
a check.
Really?
He'll wait.
Yeah.
Shoot.
What if I had bad breath in?
Oh,
let me let me handle this before anyone can smell it and check.
you know that just remind me because I laughed.
It just remind me of two things I just saw on the,
on the interwebs.
One was a person that said something negative about,
about the podcast or the book and he said this guy should just smile.
He doesn't,
he never smiles and anything.
And someone of course was like,
dude,
you might want to listen to his podcast because he laughs a lot.
And then someone else said,
this guy should just pick up a guitar.
He doesn't,
he doesn't know anything about Freedom House.
And someone else got on says he does play guitar.
So yeah.
Cool.
Haters.
Not,
not to do a little fact checking.
That's all I'm saying.
If you want to throw some hate around just to a little,
a little fact checking because we're over here laughing.
We're playing the gift box from time to time.
Say you call it to get buck.
Get bollix.
I've ever heard that before.
You got to be old school about one.
Uh,
next question.
Jacob,
do you still respect people without discipline?
Interesting.
Okay.
So first of all,
my baseline as a person just to respect people.
That's my baseline.
Now that is not the same as something we've talked about before about before,
which is that doesn't mean I expect a lot from them.
Okay?
You see the big difference there?
I respect people.
Hey,
I respect you.
Your Spec,
what you're doing.
That doesn't mean I expect that you're going to be humble or you're going to be
hardworking or you're going to be brave or you're going to even be a slightly
diff,
decent human being.
I don't expect any of that,
but,
but I,
and let me,
let me phrase this carefully.
That doesn't mean I don't treat them with respect.
Now you notice I just changed this.
Yes.
It's not just about I actually respect you.
It's,
I'm going to treat you with respect.
There's a big difference,
right?
I'm going to,
I'm going to treat everyone with respect,
but as far as actually respecting someone,
um,
no,
I'm not just automatically respect and people now will treat them with respect
because I don't know who they are.
I don't know what struggles they've had in their life.
I don't know what they've been through.
I don't know that.
So I'm going to treat him with respect.
And it's very similar,
like a Jujitsu perspective.
You don't know sp okay.
Do you get to perspective Nogi Right.
You don't know how good someone is.
You don't,
you don't.
And,
and this is another thing when you,
when you know how good someone is,
and let's say you're better than them.
If you really understand Jujitsu,
you realize that you're better than them because you've been training longer.
Yeah.
Fundamentally.
Right?
Of course.
Are there some people that are just an amazing athletes?
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
But 98% of the people,
you've just been training longer than them,
or you just were born a lot bigger than them or a lot stronger than them.
But you look at them and say,
you know what,
if this person had,
if we flip this around and this person been training longer,
I'd be the one getting crushed.
Right?
So there's that now.
So,
so yes,
I treat people with respect and my,
my attitude is generally to say,
look,
I don't know what they've been through,
so I'm going gonna I'm going to treat them that way.
Now that being said,
when someone just throws away their potential because they lack discipline,
that kind of bothers me.
I mean,
it doesn't mean that I don't respect them,
but I am definitely disappointed.
Okay.
And in conditions where there is a gross lack of discipline,
just a gross lack of discipline,
I do move beyond just mere disappointment and I do get into the realm of,
I do not respect that person because they lack discipline.
So
there you go.
So it's like a respect meter kind of thing and you're starting at the base line.
Yeah,
the thing,
yeah.
I always start with treating everyone with respect.
Yeah.
Going to treat everyone with respect.
And if you don't,
you don't know who you're disrespecting.
Yeah.
Right.
Who are you disrespect?
I mean,
you could be disrespecting me.
First of all,
you could be disrespecting someone that is,
uh,
been through a lot that maybe you should learn from.
You could be,
you know,
you're walking down the street and you disrespect.
You could disrespect someone that's a psychopath with a gun.
Yeah.
And now you're in a shootout with them.
People are getting,
you know,
I mean,
you're probably going to win if you train hard,
but still probably innocence might be,
you know,
by standards,
just don't know who.
You just know who people are.
Yeah.
That's a bird lesson to learn from Jujitsu,
man.
You don't know how good people are.
You don't know.
We're not just,
not just how well they train,
but what have they been through that day in their life.
Yeah.
Yo,
you meet some people in the wrong day and that can be really a real problem.
Yeah.
So just be careful.
And you know what's funny,
I was thinking about this,
that being said,
my uh,
my buddy from Scotland,
his name is Colin,
and he sent me a text the other day and he was listening to the podcast and he's
a very avid listener of the podcast and he said,
he said finally after 94 podcasts,
I understand what that being said means,
and he's right when he said that being said is
basically the verbalization of the dichotomy of leadership and of life and
things and of the world.
Because that means that being said is when you recognize that one side of things
is balanced by another side of things.
And it's true in everything there is,
right?
Like you could say,
Jujitsu is the best martial art.
That being said,
if someone wrestled in college and they're 262 pounds and you're 145 pounds,
it's going to be problematic for you.
And you could say about leadership,
hey,
it's good to be aggressive and assertive.
That being said,
if you're overly aggressive,
no one's going to want to work for you.
So it applies across the board.
It's those opposing forces.
So I think it's a good tool to use.
When you think about things,
what does the other side of the argument,
what is the other side of the situation and knowing and and studying the other
side will make you understand everything
better.
Yeah.
That being said,
it can be very difficult to understand anything that's life really.
So then no expectation.
And I think we talked,
I know we talked about this before,
but you say I don't have any expectations.
That's low expert,
very low experts expectation.
A lot of times people will take that as like you expect low performance out of
me,
you know,
which is different.
There's no,
no.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
You're correct.
Yeah.
Cause that essentially means that you do have expectations.
They're just like negative,
you know,
I expect like low-performance how of you,
I expect you to do the wrong thing or something like that.
My expectations are low.
My hope is high.
Yeah.
Url,
you know,
hardworking,
very diligent squared away human being.
That's so
technically,
so obviously you know the difference between expecting poor performance or just
having a clean slate.
No real expectations.
And I'm going to take things the way they come.
Obviously you know the difference there.
So what would you call when someone says,
I have low expectations of you,
I sounds like they expect you to do junk.
Yeah.
That tell us that sounds bad.
I have low expectations so,
but so put your hands up and say hey,
no expectations.
Okay.
That sounds different.
Yeah,
you're right.
I saw,
I guess I guess my expectations are closer to the no expectations.
Yeah.
I don't expect negativity.
Yes.
But I don't expect much either beings.
I like to set a low bar.
Right.
And then let them and let pleasantly impressed.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
So it's kind of like,
it'll be expectation or respect or,
and the respect meter is kind of at this cool exceptable baseline.
Right.
Just fundamental stuff fundamental.
Don't you know,
whatever,
you know,
don't step on my feet on purpose the first time you meet any kind of thing.
And then with every little action,
big or small,
with every experience with that person,
the meter either goes up or it goes down and it depends on the violation or the
whatever the element that's going to impress your right.
So let's say someone,
it's weird now you know how like people we get impressed by like stuff that
scene it seems like you're supposed to do,
did you just say we cause are you talking about me too?
I think so.
Okay.
I Dunno,
that's a total assumption,
but like,
okay,
are you impressed with people
who keep their word?
Absolutely right?
Yeah.
That's an example.
So you're supposed to keep your word.
That's what your,
where it is,
you keep it,
you know,
that's kind of what the whole defining characteristic.
So you're saying where it is you're saying some other person might say,
well I just expect people right there.
We're supposed to do that.
You know,
I remember like how Chris Rock on his little standup thing.
He'd be like,
Oh yeah,
people want like credit for stuff you're supposed to do.
Like he's like,
I can take care of my kids.
I was like,
yeah,
you're supposed to take care of your kids,
you know kind of thing.
But when you think about it,
are you impressed with someone who takes good care of their kids?
You kind of are,
right?
Yeah.
But that's not to say you expect them not to though.
Really.
It's,
you just have what I'm saying,
which is no expert close leaning towards no expectations.
And then when you experiencing,
you kind of fall on one side of it,
you know whether it'd be like,
yeah,
that makes me happy.
It makes me happy that you're doing what you're supposed to do.
That's what it is right there.
Right.
Pretty much like when you showed up today,
I was happy.
Wait,
you were at a hair show them well,
yeah,
when I showed up and saw you here,
I was happy you were here.
Oh,
that's what you're supposed to be here.
We agreed we were going to be here.
Right.
That's happy.
Well that's cool.
I guess what I was there just stoked to see me,
but yeah,
I wasn't impressed,
but I was happy.
Hmm,
okay.
I'm just trying to get to the bottom of it anyway.
I don't even know what you're getting the bottom too,
but maybe we can do another question.
Just your expectations and respect,
you know,
really the whole,
the meticulous and specific dynamics of that.
That's what we're going for there.
Okay.
I think.
Anyway,
next question.
Cool.
Real cool.
Jocko,
wha what do I do when one of my teammates isn't really pulling their weight?
They used to be pretty good,
but things have gone downhill.
How can I get,
how can I get them to fix themselves?
It has extra tricky because he's a friend of mine.
Okay,
well you got your,
your teammate slash friend that's not pulling their weight and how do you get
them back in the game?
First thing I'm going to do,
actually,
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to help them.
I'm going to help them.
I'm going to take some weight off of their shoulders.
I'm going to,
I'm going to actually step in and say,
oh yeah,
hey,
echo.
You know you've got that,
that project working on and you know what?
That little assignment you got hanging up.
How can I stay at the office a little bit late tonight?
I'm going to knock the,
just give that to me.
I'll just hammer it out tonight.
I'm going to be here anyways cause I gotta pick up my kids late from school.
Is that cool?
Just take a little way off.
Sure.
Just do what you can.
You know,
maybe just carry some,
how do you know what that person that got going on at home?
Yeah.
Right.
What are you going to jump right down their throat and get all in their face?
Make it worse and get things worse when actually that person has a sick kid or
has a problem with their husband
or wife or whatever and now we're getting in their face and getting their grill
about it.
Yeah,
no,
I'm just going to lean in and give him,
give him a hand.
That seems like what a good teammate would do,
especially if the person is your friend.
So get in there and hopefully they'll say,
hey,
thanks.
You know what?
I got this problem at home or thanks,
I've got this health issue going on and you ain't no problem.
And guess what?
We just built a little relationship.
We on it a little bit tighter.
We were friends,
now we're even a little bit tighter friends.
So that's a positive things.
Now there's also a chance of course that well and to continue down that story,
eventually they get healthier,
they resolve the problem at home and they get back in the game and then we're
all good.
And guess who the next person that might need a little assistance?
It might be you,
you might be the one with a problem with a health issue,
with a sick family member or whatever,
and you're the one that might have to lean on them.
You want them to get in your face and start yelling at you about pulling your
weight,
or do you just want them to say,
Hey,
I got some capacity right now.
Let me help you out.
Yeah,
right.
It's,
it's so clear how you want to handle that.
Number one,
you just want to take some ownership of what's going on.
Now there's also the chance that once they've come back or that you,
you help them out and they like start looking at you and saying,
Oh,
you know,
Jack was just going to do all my work for me.
Jocko was just going to,
you know,
I can just lean on him.
He's going to do everything.
Oh,
I gave him one task I'll get,
I'll let them do this other tasks that I've been assigned,
I'll let them do another task number aside.
And if people start giving me their work to do good,
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do their work,
I'm going to do their work.
And if they want me to do all of their work,
I'll do all their work and eventually they won't have a job anymore.
And then I'll take their job and then I'll have,
I'll get promoted and all hire more people that are going to do the right thing
and get after it.
Right.
So that's okay.
When,
when somebody wants to put themselves on report for being lazy by allowing you
to do work their work for them,
allow them to fill out that report in full detail.
And the other thing is,
so then do you,
do you jump up and down and say,
look,
I'm doing echoes job look,
come do.
No,
no,
no.
You don't do that.
You don't need to do that.
You may want to do it because you feel like you need to do it but you don't.
Sure you the recognition will come.
You just need to be patient.
Of course on top of all this,
there is some indirect coaching that you can do to try and get them up to speed,
you know,
as opposed to saying you're screwed up echo and said,
you say,
Hey Echo,
I got some extra capacity with what's going on.
Is there anything I can do to help you out?
You know he's,
they're getting support that you need because I know you,
you're,
this part of the task is a little bit bigger than mine.
And so you know,
is there anything I can do to help you get the job done?
Do you need any support from me?
Cause I'm,
I'm actually elevating you a little bit by saying your task is harder at
challenging in bigger and more important.
Or you can also say,
Hey,
is there anything we should we need from the boss too to help us down here?
Are there any support that we should get from up the chain of command?
Because I think if we go with a unified front,
we could get some help.
I'm actually feeling pretty good about my area of responsibilities.
But are you feeling good about yours?
Cause if not,
maybe you need some more support or we could get it from,
if we go to the boss as a unified front and make it happen,
and then you say,
Oh yeah,
well you know what?
I got this and I need another person,
or I need some more man hours,
or whatever the case may be.
We get you moving in the right direction
and that's it.
What if they're just slacking?
They're just lacking.
Cool.
Let them slide thing.
Yeah,
let him suck.
There's also,
there's also thing where a lot of times when I come and take your work from you,
if you're not just a Turd,
you'll be like,
yeah.
He's like,
Hey,
you know Jocko ea,
you did this last week.
I got it,
man.
It's no problem.
You as a human being will feel like you're not carrying the weight for the
tribe.
And when human beings feel like they're not carrying the weight for the tribe,
they,
they want to help.
They feel like they're not going to get there.
Their piece of meat.
Right.
So they want to help out.
You ever seen,
you know,
you're,
that's what your mom used to do to you and you were a kid just,
they'd just be cleaning it.
You something you feel like,
okay,
I need to help.
Yeah,
100% or you'll see,
you know,
your wife,
my wife will do that to you.
Yeah.
She'll do that to me all the time actually,
every single time.
So,
you know how like,
you know,
I don't know,
Saturday comes,
you know,
we don't have any plans on Saturday,
so I'm cruising and my waist starts taking on this kind of big cleaning project,
the garage,
whatever,
I dunno,
garage in my case.
And then she'll kind of walk and she'll be like,
hey,
you know,
what do you want me to do with this thing that I found in the back corner of the
garage?
What do you want to do this?
And then three minutes later she's back.
What do you want me to do with this thing?
Well,
no,
well,
yeah,
of course that happens all the time.
But as far as the example for this,
the comparison is she'll be like,
hey,
can you clean up this whole thing right here?
And I'll be like,
I'll be like,
oh yeah,
you know,
like I didn't really plan on that whole big project right now.
So you know,
maybe I'm kind of doing this unimportant thing or whatever.
I'll be like,
yeah,
I'll do it in a few minutes.
But then I'll see her doing it.
Oh you know what I'm saying?
And then doing my work.
All right,
I got to do it.
I can't let her do my job cause it's kind of my job now.
Well one time my wife on the opposite on the spectrum,
we were planning to Redo my backyard a little bit and we were going to put in
like a five foot retaining wall with concrete block and dig a foundation and all
that.
And then we backfill the soil to fill it up to the level of the five foot
retaining wall.
And so I kind of talked about my wife,
you know,
I was going to,
hey,
this is what we're going to do.
We're going to build this retaining wall.
We'll put some steps here or it'll be good.
We can backfill,
we'll have a level yards.
It'd be really nice and so,
so then like on a Sunday at like one o'clock in the afternoon,
she's like,
why don't you build retaining wall today?
And I was like,
you know,
it's a little late in the day for me to start that project right now.
Why you got to get it all done?
Because this was like a nine day project.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's why.
Oh,
she wanted you to build it right in there.
Hey,
what are you doing this afternoon?
If you're not doing anything,
how much you build a five foot concrete block retaining wall over here with
drainage and then backfill and put sod down.
That sounds like something you could do in the afternoon.
Yeah.
Hurry up.
Next question.
Look,
I'm not talking that good into my microphone.
Whichever Jocko.
I'm a high school teacher.
I consider myself the leader in the classroom.
How do I demonstrate extreme ownership in the classroom?
For example,
one of my students misbehaves,
how do I take extreme ownership of their behavior?
Okay,
one way to do this,
and
I do this with my kids.
I did it with my platoon guys,
couldn't do it with Jujitsu kids,
whoever.
And what you do is you do exactly what you're saying you want to do,
which is you take ownership.
So what that means is you take ownership of their behavior.
So when something goes,
when the kid's misbehaving,
okay,
you say,
Hey,
what am I not making clear to you that you continue to act like this?
Cause obviously I must be doing something wrong because I'm the teacher and
you're in here acting like an idiot and disrupting everything.
What am I not doing well?
How could I convey this message to you that that you should not like that.
Not only that,
but how can I better make you understand that what you do right now is going to
affect and impact of the rest of your whole life?
Because I want you,
I'm supposed to convey that to you as a person.
That
if you get engaged in class,
you're going to have a more successful and better life.
And that's what my kind of goal is.
And so what I want to know is how I can better explain to you,
okay
that your behavior while you're in here from classroom attendance to having big
outburst,
to skipping class,
to not turning in your homework,
to failing tests,
all those behaviors that you kind of display on a regular basis.
I need to find a better way to explain to you that the way you are acting right
now will absolutely dictate where you're going to be in the future.
And it,
and by the way,
it's not a positive thing.
It's not a positive thing at all.
Your life is going in the wrong direction.
And as a teacher,
I'm supposed to move it in the right direction.
So what do you think I could do better to help you understand that?
Hm.
So there we go.
That's,
that's,
that's one method.
And by the way,
I've used that with my kids too.
That's a very effective method for parenting.
Hmm.
Is isn't why did you not clean your room?
It's how did I fail as a father to it to make you understand that basic
fundamental hygiene is a positive thing.
Where did I,
where did I fail?
And that's actually the cleaning room example isn't a great one,
but when it's something a little bit more severe than that,
something like when they really do something that's outside of the lines,
right?
And you say instead of saying,
you know,
you went outside the lines,
you're messed up.
Instead you say,
I'm sorry that I couldn't convey to you the importance of these lines and why we
don't go out them and now,
now,
now I'm looking at you and I'm thinking,
I don't know what mistakes I made and I let you down as,
as a father because clearly you don't understand the boundaries of,
of what is good and what is bad and I feel like I let you down and that for my
kids provokes a better reaction than you that you screwed up.
I'm now going on.
The other thing you can do here is you can explain how their behavior affects
and impacts everyone else in the class and that you as the teacher is not only
responsible for their behavior,
which you are,
but you're also responsible for teaching every single person in the class
and and that you own,
that you own the education of these other kids and that you're not going to let
one kid
destroy the experience for everyone else because that is not fair and you will
not do it.
I'm not going to let that happen.
I'm not going to let you come in here and impact all these other kids with your
negativity and your bad behavior.
These kids are here to learn.
They actually want to do something with their lives.
They want to take over and dominate.
They want to win,
and I'm looking at you and I think you must want to lose because that's where,
that's where you're heading.
That's what you want to do is lose in life because these other kids,
they want to win.
So I'm not going to let that happen.
I'm not going to let them lose because you want to lose.
If you want to lose,
you can go do it on your own time in the principal's office
and then you,
maybe you have to kick them out of class.
Maybe you have to suspend them and for a while or whatever.
And
I think that then you have to let people understand that just like you take
ownership,
they should take ownership of their lives,
right?
That's the fundamental thing that you're getting at.
And lastly,
and this is something that I think is very hard for young kids to understand,
young kids,
meaning the ages between like 15 and 2025 maybe 25 some get it earlier.
You know,
some kids understand it earlier,
but understanding this thread of this,
this thread of the passage of your life and that the way that you act right now
affects the where you're going to be in a week,
in a month,
a year,
in five years and 10 years.
And kids do not understand that.
They do not understand it.
I didn't understand it when I was 10 1215 1830
you know what I mean?
Like,
well I think,
I think actually one of the things,
one of the best things for me is that when you joined the military,
they,
they show you that thread and it's very clear.
They're like,
hey,
you do this and you get promoted,
you do this and you get advanced.
You get this and you get your paycheck.
You get this.
Oh and you do this other thing.
You don't get a paycheck.
You didn't do this other thing.
You go to the Brig,
you do this other thing and you will,
you'll won't make it through seal training.
So you know,
that was for me,
I shouldn't have said get promoted because for me it was get to seal training
and get through seal training.
I didn't care about getting promoted,
I never did.
But to get,
when I was 18 years old to get to seal training and to get through seal
training,
that was a crystal clear path for me.
And I saw it and as soon as I saw it I said,
okay,
I will not veer off that path.
What they tell me to do,
I'll do now.
There's nothing that's that solid for a civilian,
right.
For civilian to say,
okay,
if you do this right now,
you're going to get into this college.
If you get into this college and you get these kinds of grades,
you're going to get this kind of job.
There's no real clear path like that and so it's harder to draw that thread for
people,
but I think you can do it.
I think you're going to show examples of,
of,
of where you end up in the societal structure based on your behavior as a
teenage person.
A teenage human.
Yeah.
That's going to be hard just straight up.
That's just going to be hard for a teacher because,
because of the time constraints like that or the time limitations that you have
with the,
with the kid.
Yeah.
I think one thing that is I've done with with my kids is I look at other human
beings in the world with them and I explained to them that that's a person
that's a person.
I was talking about this with my son.
It left such an impact on him.
Yesterday we were down at the beach early morning one time,
years ago,
he was probably probably eight years old.
We were going surfing waves were good by the way.
It was a big day.
Hell yeah,
we got done.
And so now it's seven 38 o'clock in the morning and there's a guy that's an
obvious drug induced state of mayhem and he's got five cops and they get him
down and we're watching this whole thing and he's yelling,
swearing,
and they,
they put a spit bag on his head.
So he's just full on crazy.
And you know,
my son saying,
what is that dad?
You know,
and say,
oh that's a bag so that this guy doesn't spit on these police officers that are
down here doing their job.
And,
you know,
I said,
this is what happens when you go on drugs.
This is where you end up.
You end up with no shirt on one shoe,
a rip jeans,
you,
you have a spit back on your head,
you're handcuffed and you're going to jail.
That's where you end up.
That's where the path leads.
So don't do those things.
Don't,
don't start down that path.
And it's the same thing.
You know,
I was with my daughter and we saw,
what did we see?
I was pointing out to her again,
someone,
a woman that clearly didn't have a place to live.
Um,
you know,
she was a homeless person and I,
walking with my daughter and we see the woman with the shopping cart and it's
filled with,
you know,
stuff,
crap and sleeping bags and cans and whatever.
Clearly a homeless person but was weird.
And the reason I specifically pointed out was because she looked somewhat,
somewhat normal and yet you could tell that she was not doing well.
And so,
you know,
I said to my daughter,
I said,
what do you think of of that person?
And she's obsessed.
I Dunno,
what do you mean?
I said,
well,
do you think that person wants to be there?
And she said,
well,
we'll know.
And I said,
well,
how do you think she ended up there?
And she said,
I don't know.
And I said,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know either.
But that's a real person.
And when she goes to bed tonight,
she's going to be underneath a bridge somewhere.
It's going to be cold.
She's going to be wet,
she's going to be miserable.
And that is how,
that's her life.
That's where she ended up.
So some choices that she made along the way may have contributed to that.
And what I'm saying to you is make choices that will contribute to you not
ending up in that position.
Because those people that you see that are homeless,
that are addicted to drugs,
those people are actually people and you can,
it's very easy to view them as all,
I could never be there.
They're not,
there are different species than me.
They're not.
That's,
I guess that's the,
that's the point of my story is that it's really easy for people to look at
other people and think that that's not,
I could never be there.
That could not happen to me.
And my point to my kids is,
Oh yes it can.
If you make the wrong choices it,
hey,
you know what?
You're going to be bad luck.
Sure it can be bad luck.
It can be bad luck.
But most of the time,
the vast majority of time it's decision making,
bad decision making,
get you in bad situations.
And by the way,
people that go off the path and,
and then they say,
you know what?
I screwed up.
I did the wrong thing and I'm going to now fix it.
That's,
you don't see people like that that are homeless.
You don't see people like that at a better addicted to drugs because they take
responsibility and they say,
okay,
I made this mistake.
I didn't do the right things.
I need to get fixed.
And they fix it.
Whereas someone that says,
oh it's my parents' fault and it's my boyfriend's fault and it's my girlfriend's
fault and it's my old bosses fault and it's my pushers fault.
And whoever you want to blame,
it's,
if it's not your fault,
you don't have,
you don't fix the problem,
you don't take ownership of the problem,
you don't fix it on a personal level.
And that's problematic.
Yeah.
Your parents were teachers,
Huh?
Yes.
Both teachers.
Yeah.
Make that there's a lot of,
it seems like there's a lot of similarities with teachers and then parents.
Right?
Cause it's both like you're both trying to guide these young lines.
Sure.
By the way,
kids,
teenagers,
whatever.
Yeah.
They can't really have United say they don't understand the correlation between
like their actions now they,
they kind of can't because that part of their brain isn't developed it the front
part,
uncle,
whatever,
what's called the front part.
That's off the tech part.
I think that's the medical term,
but it tends to on average or whatever,
develop by age 25 that's why I said,
oh 25 okay.
So that's typically,
you know,
give or take when it,
when it's done developing.
So yeah,
before that.
And it's basically the decision making like,
okay,
what I just,
what he said,
what I do now affects the future.
And you know,
like now you're like,
oh,
when you do something,
you can almost feel the payoff in the future.
It's almost like that,
you understand it.
No.
Back then you couldn't,
that's why these colleges that when you go to college at 18 or 17,
in my case,
they all,
all these credit card,
little credit card pushers,
they'll just post up outside of your dorm room and be like,
Hey,
an unsecured,
I don't even know what unsecured means,
by the way,
at this time,
a $300 limit,
just crit credits,
free money.
It's free money.
That's how they do all you gotta do is fill out this thing.
And everyone,
of course,
I don't know what that means.
I'll pay it back whole way later.
So they get you like that.
But nonetheless,
um,
yeah,
so they don't have that part of their brain.
They don't know.
So the answer is I'm Kinda drawing from my childhood.
So I had these two teachers,
right?
One teacher's name was Mr Takita Japanese guy and he was like a little summer I
Ninja guy.
He didn't really talk that much like outside of the classroom.
And when he'd talk in the classroom it was all deliberate stuff.
There was no small talk.
It was really rigid.
We had a quiz every single Friday,
every single Friday came questions,
real short quiz about the weak stuff.
He's a little lecture on the board was like boom,
boom,
boom.
I think he'd even underlying the key points,
you know,
so you'd know there was,
there was no like,
hey read this and I'm going to just,
you know,
mystery.
This is where you can be done.
He underlined the key points and you got to know those key points.
At the end of the week test every week,
boom you take or quiz,
it's quiz,
then there's a test on all this stuff or whatever.
But you are not ill equipped for these tests.
You knew as long as you're showing up,
paying,
attending,
you knew so either you did it or you didn't do it,
you know,
so it was,
and there was no like,
hey guys,
nothing that you could,
you knew what to expect.
This guy was so consistent with every,
every little thing all the way down to the like if you call them Takita cause
sometimes that's how you know when you get real chummy with it,
with the teachers,
just in general,
if you're that kind of person,
you won't say mister or Mrs. Right.
So some everyone saw,
you'd be like,
Hey,
I don't know Smith,
we'll just see if the teacher's name was Mrs. Smith.
He'd be like,
Hey Smith.
And you know,
it's a kind of chummy relationship.
So one time I forget who it was,
it might've been this girl Cressey.
Anyway,
he goes,
oh Quito.
Cause she like,
don't mean he was a likable guy.
That's the thing.
But um,
but just really consistent and rigid,
like a Ninja or something.
And they were like,
Hey Takita and ask a question.
And he didn't get mad or nothing like that.
He just answers a court real stoic.
This answers the question.
And as he's shuffling his papers like this,
just real life,
this guy was sup,
cold,
cold as ice guy.
He goes like this,
boom.
He answers a question and it goes,
and that's Mr to Quito.
And then he just continues on.
Right?
And I was like,
Dang,
that was fucking awesome.
But anyway,
I did the best in that class because it was one of those things that it was so
consistent,
but there was no room for slack.
If,
if you slacked off,
it was really apparent.
Discipline Equals Freedom,
you know?
But he wasn't the kind of like,
he wouldn't yell at you.
It wasn't that I don't yell.
Yeah.
So discipline equals freedom.
You don't need to yell when you,
when people understand expectations and the thing and you'd like this to where
your real consistent.
That's a thing too.
Cause you know how sometimes,
let's say you're real rigid one week and then the next layer is bad.
Or let's say you're,
you're really rigid like the whole year.
And then,
I don't know.
You're not,
you're feeling,
I don't know,
you're hung over or something.
I don't know.
You partied or something.
You come to class as the teacher by the way.
Um,
and then you're not as rigid that day.
Oh,
there's the little,
there's a little chink in your,
in your armor there and they'll kind of start to exploit it.
These kids,
which brings me to my second teacher,
not going to say his name,
he was in seventh grade though,
where this guy was just all over the place.
Super easy to take advantage of this guy.
He's a music teacher.
Wait,
was he made you?
Yeah,
I think so.
I don't know.
I forget,
but super easy to take advantage of this guy.
But kind of like,
he loses cool all the time and you know,
it was just funny to see them react a lot of the time.
Right.
And the thing is,
he didn't start like that.
He started just super nice,
just like,
hey look,
kind of like people would run over him and he'd be like,
Hey,
you know,
we don't have to,
he was just super nice,
but it wasn't consistent with anything.
Then after awhile,
I think it was after like a few years,
um,
I hear that he's like really mean now.
Like he loses his temper all the time.
I'm like,
what the heck is,
it goes back to just disappointing because freedom.
Right?
And if you would have held the line in the beginning and said,
no,
you don't act like that in stop.
Then if he would have stopped at the minimal or at this small action that was
bad,
this,
this small,
bad behavior,
if he tightened that up,
then it would never get to bed.
Then he doesn't have to lose his temper and get crazy.
And I'm sure he's a nice guy.
I'm sure he's a positive guy and he had the highest hopes and expectations.
It's going back to the earlier subject.
He had the really high hopes that everyone's going to be in here to learn and,
and open their minds.
And it's like,
no,
these kids are in here to shoot spitballs and stick pencils into the back of the
person sitting in front of them.
Right.
That's sort of it sort of it.
And when you realize that then you don't allow that middle bill behavior and
then they just don't get totally out of control.
Yeah man.
Hard,
hard work being a teacher.
Very much so.
Very much though.
Cause again like,
cause
it goes back to the thing men where were,
you only have like what an hour or something when the 45 minutes in a day and
that's the only for like five days maximum for the week,
sometimes less.
You know,
you've got all of these whatever and then they go home or wherever and then they
get their influences,
you know,
boom,
boom.
As they grow up,
then they come back to your class with all that influence and it's like,
what,
what?
Now?
You know,
and you got to kind of find a way as the teacher,
not only to like get through to them,
just person to person,
but you've got to get all this material.
And if they don't like that material,
Oh man,
that's yet another task.
You know?
So again,
man,
if you have that,
that structure in place and it's consistent and they know what to expect,
that's going to help because they have the scaffolding.
They don't know how to make it.
You know,
I got asked one time by a teacher,
it's kind of a similar question,
you know,
I've done everything to get through to this person act.
They're just not,
they're just not getting in the game.
What do I do now?
And I was like,
well,
try a different way.
Trying to try a different way,
you know,
you didn't get through to them that way.
Try it a different way.
How can you get through it now?
Just like as a boss,
as a leader,
as a platoon commander,
if you've tried every single possible different way and you've got someone that
just cannot do it or does not want to do it,
and they're negatively effecting everyone else,
then it's your responsibility as a leader to get rid of them,
get rid of them.
And had another conversation with a teacher one time who had kicked someone out
of her school for fighting and I,
and,
and this,
this person's a great person.
And a friend of mine,
she kicked someone out of the school and we met at a,
at a dinner,
and we were just talking and I said,
oh,
how's everything going?
She goes,
well,
you know,
I just kick this person out of school.
And I was like,
oh,
what's the situation?
And she swell,
you know,
it's this guy,
this kid,
and he's been a good kid.
He doesn't come from a great home,
but he got into a fight.
He hit another kid and I just have,
no,
we can't have that at school at all.
And so me being a jerk,
I was like,
oh,
so you just destroyed his,
his life basically.
And she,
and you know,
and she's like,
what do you mean?
I go,
well,
if the kid doesn't have much of a home and he's not coming from a great family,
the only thing he has is your school.
And if you don't allow them in school now you kicked him out.
Where's he gonna end up?
I go,
did you,
did you already open up a space warm in prison somewhere?
Because that's where he's headed.
And I was just,
I was Kinda,
I was being a total jerk,
but I didn't really realize that until I saw her like getting emotional.
And I was like,
oh,
I'm sorry.
And so then we had the conversation and what was great was we talked and we went
through this conversation.
And because what I was saying,
even though I was being a jerk about it,
even though I was being kind of,
I don't know,
I wasn't being sarcastic,
I was just being really a really offensive because she's a friend,
you know?
And that's how I am.
Like one of your field team.
Yeah,
exactly.
Treating her like another seal.
But then we talked and I said,
look,
but even though I'm,
I don't mean to be a jerk,
I'm telling like what I believe to be the truth cracking.
But you're,
you have a great school,
you have this great opportunity for these kids.
And this kid who has been well behaved was,
oh,
and this was the other critical part.
The kid that he got in a fight with the kid that he punched,
he sucker punched the guy,
not soccer punch,
but threw the first punch.
The other kid was the class jerk,
the class picking on people and always misbehaving.
That kid didn't get kicked out of the school.
He wasn't going to get kicked out of the school because he didn't actually get
involved in the physical violence and,
and so then I told her that too.
I said,
look,
you got one kid that he finally broke mentally and you've got another kid that
just knows how to push people's buttons and he wanted him to hit him and now
you're kicking the kid out.
That actually probably should have done what he did.
He,
that kid probably deserve to get punched in the face.
And,
and anyways,
after this long conversation,
you know,
she went back in the other,
the other key little thing that we talked about was I said,
it's okay for you as a leader to say,
hey look,
I made a mistake.
You know what?
I'm not kicking him out of the school.
You know why?
Because this other kid acted like a jerk.
This other kid harassed him,
this other kid did these other kid things and this child has been a well behaved
child and he lost his temper and that's human and we're going to keep them in
school.
And she did that.
So my point is it's a hard job and
yeah,
that's my point.
Big Man.
And that's,
and that's another yet another thing that I think we've got to balance this in
regular society too,
but it's still this kid,
right?
For example,
your example where the kid punched in the gut.
So boom,
we have this incident.
So what do you do though?
Right?
It's like that's a problem if he,
and as far as problem solving goes,
you don't punish the kid.
You evaluate what happened and then you essentially help the kids.
So he doesn't function.
Right?
Like some people,
they're like,
hey,
we've got to punish this kid somehow give them detention or something.
And does that solve the problem?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe we actually teach someone to control their emotions.
Exactly right?
Like why'd you punch him?
By the way,
this guy did this.
Okay,
there's another problem by the way.
So we've got to teach this kid to stop messing around.
Right.
That way,
you know?
And then we got to teach
this kid,
okay,
if you get,
you get messed around.
Yeah,
you're right.
And sometimes the only way some kids learn a lesson is by being severely
punished,
kicked out of a school,
whatever,
you know,
expelled or something like that.
But most cases,
what most cases,
what does that really teach them that,
that that's cool.
Doesn't care about them.
Right.
So that's a tough situation.
You know,
interestingly in where the warrior kid,
the next book that's coming out the hole,
and I'm not going to give the whole story away,
but the,
the opening chapter,
young mark is in the principal's office and he's in the principal's office
because he threw a paper,
Mashiach Pumpkin at another kid's head.
Why did he do it?
Because he was frustrated because he got mad because the kid was picking on him
continually,
uh,
verbalizing verbal abuse.
And finally mark just got mad and he hooked a paper,
Mashiach Pumpkin at the kid's head.
It bounced off the kid's head and hit and hit Ms. Carpenter at the phase two.
So we got sent to the office.
But anyways,
but the point is,
where I,
the reason I did that is because kids that are 11 years old,
they still lose their temper.
They haven't learned to control your temper yet.
And so one of the themes in the new or your kid book is that a warrior has to
learn to control their temper and control their emotions.
The lessons that we're talking about right now.
Yeah.
Interesting
it off.
So thanks to the teachers out there,
big time man.
Cause man as a t and I've never been a teacher,
he asleep.
But I mean just even halfway imagining it man,
you kind of care about these kids but you care about them all.
So,
and then you have all the,
the whole spectrum of them.
You have the kid who's like the teacher's bit as far as the other kids are
concerned.
But meanwhile you love that kid cause man,
he's picking up what you're putting down and he's listening and he's giving you
apples and whatnot.
Then you have on the other side,
you have the one that won't listen to anything disrupting your class,
you know?
But you want that kid like of course you want him to leave you like stop messing
up my whole thing.
But you're like,
yeah man.
Cause like when you know how you teach someone something and you see a music,
oh man,
that's the best as any kind of capacity that you know as far as the role that
you play,
like in Jujitsu or something like that.
Even like another adult because they're all the same.
Right.
Actually,
I think kids,
well,
there's assume there's a fundamental human characteristic,
I believe that makes you want to help other people.
Yeah.
It feels like you're just going to influence like living on or something like
that.
I don't know,
but man,
so it's like,
then it's like,
yet that's yet another thing you got to deal with as a teacher.
You know,
because you're committed men.
It's like shoretel.
Anyway,
next question.
Question.
I'm a firefighter.
Speaking of which,
I'm a fighter firefighter in Australia and in the time I've been in this job,
I've been to several jobs
that were very challenging.
I've entered burning homes to extinguish fires and search for residents and
their pets.
I searched for victims during times flood and help people evacuate their homes.
In terms of natural disasters,
I've attended car crashes and cut victims from vehicles and pulled deceased
people from others.
I also know that I'm not alone.
I am aware of the fact that while I've been doing this,
countless firefighters were on the globe war thousands of times braver than me,
and I've done things that the vast majority of the population would not be
capable of,
and that doesn't even acknowledge the courage of our police and paramedics in
our military who step up day after day to do what has to be done because of,
if not me,
then who?
My question is this,
how do you suggest those and the front line deal with the trivial issues at
home,
I attended a very severe car accident,
a head on collision with a school bus full of children and another car.
Thankful.
Thankfully all the children in the school bus broke.
Okay.
But it took us three hours to cut the driver from the car and she had very
serious injuries and was airlifted to a hospital.
When I got home that night,
I was confronted by an upset girlfriend wanting to talk about some extra
extraordinarily trivial issue,
which I struggled to listen to the whole time.
And she was talking.
I just kept thinking about the job and making sure I,
I'd done everything I possibly could have for the driver,
but I was also aware of the fact that my fiancee's problems are important to
her,
so I need to be supportive.
I listen for as long as I could.
Then unfortunately,
I just said,
your day could have been a lot worse.
No one spent three hours cutting you out of a car,
so be thankful.
I know I can't be alone on this.
I know police paramedics in the military would be suffering the same thing.
How do you suggest is the best way to deal with this
check?
So
it was
always,
always my goal to protect my family from darkness and evil in the world.
That includes these kinds of things.
You want to shield them from this.
Now this doesn't mean to keep them oblivious.
You don't want them thinking that though the world that you've created for them
that's well protected and secure.
You don't want them thinking that that's the way the whole world is.
You don't want them thinking that,
but I sure didn't throw this kind of stuff at my family on a regular basis.
But I took pride and I think that that's the answer here.
Take Pride in letting your family or your loved ones live in worlds where
they're trivial issues.
Okay.
Are the most important thing in their world,
the most impactful thing in the world for them.
Okay.
So that's,
that's number one.
And if you get yourself a little bit of,
of satisfaction every time your,
your significant other complains that um,
you know,
the,
the ice machine isn't really working up to full speed.
It's really horrible.
Right?
You should be,
you should be proud of think of yourself.
Yeah.
Well you know what,
let me,
let me take a look at it.
Maybe there's a kink in the water line.
I don't know.
But we'll try and get that thing up to speed so you can have cold drinks.
Cause that's where I want your world to be,
right?
I want you to have plenty of ice,
so for your drinks or whatever.
Uh,
so that's,
that's it.
If you can give,
you can put your family in that kind of a protected environment.
You should be proud of it and you should be.
And the way they indicate that to you,
they don't say,
hey thank you for letting me live in a protected environment.
They don't say that to you.
They,
they're in the environment.
They don't even know that they're in it.
The way they,
the way they let you know that they're in that environment is when they,
when they complain about trivial things.
So that's number one.
The other thing is try and try and see things from other people's perspectives.
You know,
in,
in this case,
my,
my wife's right to my,
my wife would say things is a big deal to her and for her it was a big deal and
like I just said,
I wanted it to be a big deal for her.
And also I'll tell you what we're talking about firefighters and military and
police,
but this goes to other non uniformed jobs as well.
If,
if you can leave your work at work cause you think some,
you know,
every job there's stresses at every job and you're out there grinding and you're
in trouble with the boss or you're trying to get a project fee figured out and
you've got all this stress coming down on you or you've lost money or you've got
a huge deal on the table or whatever the case may be.
If you can isolate your family from that as much as you can.
And I'm not saying to an unhealthy level where you're just not telling them
what's going on,
but bear the burden man,
bear the burden of that you,
that you hold to protect your family.
So yeah.
Um,
that's what I think.
That's what I think we,
we do our best to protect our family and our loved ones from the darkness,
the pressure,
the stress,
the evil in the world.
Again,
you don't make them oblivious.
You don't disconnect from them in order to do that.
But you shield him from it and you bear the burden yourself so that they don't
have to bear it as much.
Again,
you don't want your kids growing up to be spoiled.
You don't want your wife to be saying,
if I don't get have a latte this morning,
I will absolutely not even.
Right.
You don't want to be married to that person.
Yeah.
Not even.
I did that pretty good,
didn't I?
One of my middle daughter's like the funniest person ever and she can do all
these crazy,
I'm stealing material right there
because she'll do that.
She'll say,
she'll say God is so,
Oh my God.
It's not even,
you know,
she's kidding.
Cause she knows that there's human beings like that in the world that say not
even,
there's nothing at the end of it.
I think that might be something new that's not evil.
You know,
I've heard I can't even,
I can't even,
oh,
it's the same thing.
Same thing.
Yeah.
Some updated new age is just a different angle on it.
But yeah.
Hey,
thanks for all.
Thanks for doing all that hard work,
man.
That's,
um,
that's awesome.
I know,
I see firefighters,
police officers,
military people all the time.
I hear from all the time and yeah,
try and shield your family as much as you can.
Don't drag them down the down into the darkness whether you,
yeah,
it seems like a good one.
Take pride in it.
That's what I was going to.
Exactly.
What is the thing it's like take pride in.
It's like embracing the role has luck to captain kind of thing.
You know,
where it's like,
yeah.
You know,
wife's mad about,
you know,
they put cream in our coffee and she asked for non fat milk from thankful.
Um,
and you know,
whatever.
And she's pissed.
And meanwhile,
you know,
you just pulled a lady out for three hours by the way,
bus and car crashed head on collision.
So is he,
you know,
you embrace the role.
It's like,
okay,
you know,
boom,
I'm dealing off one second.
I'm dealing with straight up life and death and kids and accidents and tragedy.
And then one second later I'm dealing with essentially nothing.
Right.
But it's my wife feelings.
That's what I'm dealing with.
My wife feel I'm not dealing with nonfat milk versus cream.
I'm not dealing with that.
I'm dealing with my wife's feelings.
And that's part of the job too.
So you can't just be like,
Hey,
I'm going to do my job one second.
I'm doing my job really good and the next second I'm not going to do it.
So good.
You can't do that.
Embrace the role as the guy who gets the job done regardless of how big,
how small.
So,
so as a husband,
this is where I can speak from because I'd been a husband for eight years,
um,
successfully because I'm currently husband too.
Uh,
so there'd be,
you know how like people have little things,
please,
Ciao.
Cause I need that info anyway.
But she'll,
so you know how you know people,
they'll,
they'll tell you something and then you'll be like,
wait,
what did you mean by that?
You're kind of offended.
Like,
are you like,
are you kind of digging at me?
Or something like that,
you know,
like that kind of stuff.
Even though,
you know,
kind of,
they were right.
Like that was a little passive aggressive little comment kind of thing.
So every once in a while when I experienced that,
not to say it happens all the time,
but if it ever happened,
what I do to kind of combat the anger cause Bro,
I'm the king.
I'm the kind of more like if there's like a,
so your same password aggressive from your wife.
Yes.
And what you would do to combat the anger would be,
it would be trying to move this story.
Bracing.
No,
it's relevant to this though.
And important.
I think it helps.
I totally helps where I embraced the role of the,
I don't know,
for lack of better than the captain,
you know,
embrace the role.
Captain wear
shirts,
he's passive aggressive,
whatever,
you know,
maybe I'll overtime I'll start to understand more or whatever.
But so I
envisioned myself as superman and her passive aggressive comments or bullets and
they were just bouncing off of me.
Just like bullets off.
Superman continue.
That's cool.
Until the fact that if you don't react and she's going to escalate,
she wants some kind of reaction out of you.
Yeah.
So sometimes you have to give them some kind of reaction.
Otherwise,
they'll continue to escalate to a point where you do react.
Yes.
Yeah.
So I mean that will all a while ago.
Yeah,
no reaction is,
is not always good.
Right.
So,
and I don't gotta say you gotta say the bullet hits you and you got her to say,
oh,
that,
that bullet hurt.
Oh,
um,
yeah.
I,
I should be a little more careful with the bullets are flying around.
That's how I need to be a little bit more,
you know,
careful of these bullets.
They can really hurt me.
Right.
Be careful,
but see how your,
your tone and stuff is like there's no anger there,
but the,
so that's what I meant.
I meant it's just to combat the anger,
not the,
the problem solving thing.
That's a whole nother thing as far as I'm concerned.
Like if she's passive aggressive or mad about,
I don't know,
because I put the dish away when it was wet and you know,
before it dried it,
what it was,
by the way.
But I'm just saying if it's,
that's a whole different thing.
So if I,
anger wise,
the bullets bounce off of me.
Boom.
I don't get angry,
then I can start addressing those issues.
The ones that you're talking about,
but I mean to combat the straight up anger,
keep your emotions in check,
stifling like or insults or bouncing off of me like Superman.
It helps sometimes most of the time.
All right,
next question
Jocko.
I'm leading a project that involves a few of my team members and about 10 other
team members from other functions.
The project has high visibility in the large organization,
over 10 billion in revenue that I worked for us.
So the pressures to execute is high.
We have had some issues with cross functional team members meeting their
deliverables and keeping the,
to keep the project on path,
but we're pushing sometimes dragging everyone along to make things happen.
Recently on a formal review with the leadership team,
the question was asked,
why is this project behind?
I'm a firm believer in providing protection for your team.
So my response was they're excuses,
but to be honest,
they're just excuses.
So we're doing everything we can to get it back on track,
trying to take the brunt of the performance miss on my shoulders.
No additional comments were made in that meeting and it ended.
My boss was on the call and pull me aside the next day and voiced his opinion
that I should not hesitate to call out the lack of performance on the other
functional team members.
His thought is that doing so does not allow the leadership to coach,
mentor,
and or fix issues correctly.
I understand this logic,
but I don't feel that true leaders point fingers or throw others under the bus.
Your thoughts would be,
okay,
so first of all,
your boss
has a little bit of a point,
but it's,
but it's also,
there's some limitations to it.
Number one,
you know,
our goal as a leader is to build relationships with people,
accomplish the mission,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So if,
if we,
if we start just calling people out in front of a senior leadership on a call,
well,
are you forming a good relationship with people?
The answer is no.
You're actually making them mad and they're saying they're there.
The first thing you're going to do when you call them out as call,
call you up as soon as the call ends and they're going to say,
dude,
why don't you tell me that?
Why are you telling me this in front of the boss?
So here's the deal.
You should not ever have to throw someone under the bus without plenty of
warning,
right.
Without plenty of them to to know and expect and be prepared with an answer.
That's what you should be doing.
It's kind of like that escalation of counseling.
Then I talk about like you start off by just saying,
hey man,
you were late.
You know what's up and you go all the way to like,
okay,
if you're late again and there's a whole slow escalation or depending on how
fast you need to get it done,
but with this one,
it's the same thing.
You say,
Hey,
echo,
you know you're,
you're part of the project.
What do you need help right now?
What's going on you,
you don't seem up to speed.
And then it,
then we escalate to,
hey echo,
you just missed another,
you know,
target date,
this is the second target date you've missed.
We get,
we had a problem and then it's hey echo,
do you not have the supports that you need?
What do you need because this isn't working out.
And then it's the only way I'm going to be able to do this.
So we got to bring us up to the boss.
I think you need more people.
And then that's another important thing is,
is you frame it,
you frame it in such a way that is not hurting them,
but it's actually helping them.
So I might say on the call,
Hey,
you know,
uh,
Alpha team is working really hard but they need more x,
Y,
and Z to get the job done.
So,
you know,
I think we should give echo and Alpha team more x,
y,
and Z.
Okay.
Cause he missed a date and I know they're working hard or you say,
you know,
I think we need more people allocated over to Alpha team.
I think they've been over tasks and they could use some support.
So let's give them some more people.
Or you can even say I'm moving to people from my team over to Alpha team
temporarily to give them some additional capacity over there cause they're task
is more demanding than what I've been assigned.
So all of those things are letting everyone know,
bringing the problem to the attention of the,
of the group so that now you say,
actually Jocko,
here's what's going on.
I don't need two more people.
I need four nor more people or you know,
you say,
okay,
um,
hey,
I don't need anyone else.
If you're one of those people,
the ego gets in the way and you say,
I don't need anyone else.
And we will say,
okay,
well you missed two time marks,
you miss two,
you know,
dates.
Well,
I don't need any more people.
Okay.
Okay,
well let's see if you can,
if you can make this next,
next date,
then I guess you don't,
but if you miss another day,
well then I guess you need more people.
So we,
we moved through it like that.
So yeah,
you do have to discuss things you can do.
You can discuss these things,
you can bring them up in a way.
They are not offensive to two people.
They don't throw them under the bus,
but they do however,
signify that the buses around and that if we aren't careful,
you might get hit by the bus and you got to give people plenty of warning.
It's the same thing with same thing I've talked about in the past with skipping
the chain of command.
You know,
you shouldn't be skipping the chain of command on less unless you've given so
much warning and you do it in such a way that you know,
they uh,
they actually know what's going to happen.
They expect is gonna happen and they kind of agree with you.
So be careful with those things.
Again,
if someone's doing something immoral,
illegal,
unethical,
and you skip the chain of command because you've already tried to solve with
them and they're not doing it well,
then you might have to just go get some.
Cause if you're,
you're culpable if you don't.
So formed good relationships with people.
Don't form antagonistic relationships.
You know,
I just add a conversation with a guy when I was in,
in Boston,
similar situation,
but you know,
he,
he was saying there was a situation he was in
and what he said was politically it was,
he didn't want to address it because politically if he dressed it,
it might explode.
And I said,
well,
if,
if the,
if it addressed,
if you address the situation,
like a classic case,
I know how to do this more efficiently,
this experienced person doesn't want to try my method.
Okay.
And I said,
well,
why don't you present them with the method and say,
um,
you know,
hey,
here's,
here's how we should do this.
And he says,
no,
I don't want to do that because the person that I want to get to use the new
method is really close friends with the boss and [inaudible] form that bad
relationship and it's going to be bad.
And I go,
would that affect your overall mission to your ability to do the mission,
to have bad relationships,
not only with your immediate boss,
both with your boss's boss,
and he's like,
yes it would,
and I go,
then it doesn't sound like a good plan.
There you go.
There's your answer.
Because even though you have a better method,
and you might say like a direct,
a person with a direct train of thought mindset would say,
no.
You Go,
you tell the bosses boss that this is the method and we're going to be more
efficient if we do it this way.
Well now you've just exploded a bomb on yourself and it's going to be bad.
So I gave him the classic,
Hey,
why don't you say,
listen,
I think I've thought of a new method.
I think we might be able to get some efficiencies out of it,
but since I'm not as experienced and don't know the systems as well as you do,
I would love to get your feedback on how it works.
I think that you're the only one that could really know how to do this
concealer,
so experienced and smart and brilliant,
all that stuff and awesome and you try and feed him some of the new methods so
that he can try it and either say,
yeah,
this stuff's pretty good.
Or you know what?
There's some things that you didn't realize,
young buck and we've got to get them fixed.
So check,
try and form relationships,
positive relationships,
not antagonistic relationships.
If you throw people under the bus,
you're not forming good relationships.
Check especially that surprise on.
That's rough.
Yeah.
Next question,
to give you a little backstory,
I tried my first Jujitsu class last week and during the rolling part of the
class happened to get matched up with another white belt who has been going to
the gym for over a year.
During the rule,
I got thrashed around a bit and tap to what I've been told was called a cross
collar choke.
I ended up getting geeky burns on my neck,
MFAs the game right there as well as getting my lip split,
gets up every train Muay Thai and sparked for a couple of years.
I'm used to physical pain and that's,
and that didn't exactly bother me.
What did bother me when some marks that that were left on my face,
which in addition to just not looking good,
I can't have because my job requires that I meet with clients face to face in
these clients might make judgments and assume I was in a street fight.
I also think the white belt I was rolling with went a little too hard on me,
but I don't know enough about Jujitsu to determine whether or not people go full
speed.
Every role.
I know that in when we tie box inboxing,
normally we try to tone down the intensity level.
For newbies,
especially the first time they spar.
So my questions are one,
does Jujitsu normally leave you with lots of marks or scrapes on your face?
I don't mind occasionally getting them but can't go home with them after every
class.
That's it.
Or first question.
Second question,
do people normally go full speed in rolling and if not,
how do I get him to stop without sounding like a giant wimp?
Okay.
So number one,
does BJJ normally leave you with Watson marks?
Description of your face?
The answer is no.
Not Normally.
Will you?
Occasionally,
yes you will.
Actually,
you will get dinged up.
You'll get black eyes,
you'll split your lab,
your have ghee,
Barnes on your face yet scratchy.
Yeah.
That,
that'll,
that's going to happen.
Did,
but it's not regular.
It's not regular.
It's what do you think once every three weeks on your face and neck?
Yeah,
once every three weeks.
Every three weeks,
four weeks.
I want to see maybe once a month you have something visible while you're wearing
a suit.
Presenting to clients,
given the normal amount of training,
you know,
turning wants to trade up competitive,
mode two times a day,
three days a week in a door.
Of course.
Yeah.
It's more but normal training.
Um,
and then the next question is,
do people normally go full speed and rolling?
And if not,
how do I get him to stop without sounding like a giant wimp?
So this is actually funny because if you think about it,
think about this.
He's kind of complaining in a way that the other person was going to hard,
right?
Yes.
And yet he didn't tap to this until his face was scraped and got thrashed
around.
So what I'm saying is it takes two people to escalate a situation and without
knowing it,
he escalated the situation
cause he resisted as hard as he could.
He's only been training for a day and he's going to,
they're fighting like crazy instead of just relaxing and being like,
hey,
you know,
I've only been true.
I've never trained before.
Oh,
you're going to choke me out.
Cool.
Yeah.
You know,
instead of learning and relaxing,
uh,
you,
you allow yourself to get caught up in the primal instinct of fighting for your
life,
which is what happens when people start.
You did to the primal instinct takes over and it's also ego and,
and the will to win,
it takes over.
And they just want to go so hard and they can't believe that this little guy's
joking me,
that mock gonna let it happen.
So that is actually your ego and,
and it is also your ego.
And I tell people all the time,
one of the main reasons people get hurt in Jujitsu's because of ego.
And you either don't tap number one,
which is just stupid,
or you,
you don't say no to rolling with people that you know you should enroll with.
That's it.
And when I say don't tap,
it's like,
it has to do with,
with the way you're rolling too,
right?
I mean,
if you're just going to fight everything so super hard because you want to win,
well then you're gonna end up having a much higher chance of getting injured.
So I fall into that sometimes too.
You know,
if I'm like I had a hurt knee the other day and you know,
maybe like a month ago my knee was a little hurt and I was rolling but I hadn't
been doing a lot of standup and all of a sudden I was escalating with whoever
would like hey Andy or someone and all of a sudden I was standing and I didn't
want to give up the position.
Right.
And as I'm standing there I'm like,
oh this is your ego right now you,
you,
you have no reason to sit here and fight on the feet where your,
where your knee is actually bothering you just don't be an idiot and just pull
guard and,
and so no big deal.
Right.
Okay.
Pull guard,
whatever.
Did you pull guard?
I did.
Yeah.
Cause I was realized I was being stupid and if I'm there I am,
I've been healing and I'm almost good to go and now I'm going to jeopardize it
because I just,
I want to stand up and get some stupid stupid.
So that is what you have to do.
You have to put your ego in check.
And that is a huge part of Jujitsu.
That's one of the things that makes you Jitsu so impactful.
It's,
it's so humbling.
Your ego can't withstand it.
And despite how hard you fought against this guy and this question,
that guy was still gonna tap you out.
You didn't stand a chance.
Yeah.
My first class versus the guy who had been ruling for over a year,
over a year.
You don't stand a chance.
You don't.
So what,
what you want to do is you want to learn.
So put your ego aside,
relax,
talk.
And if you get someone that's going so you don't want to sound like a wimp,
that's what gets you hurt.
What's cool is when somebody is 58 years old and they're on the mat and some
some 22 year old blue belt that weighs 80 pounds more than them says who your
one role.
And the older dude says,
no man,
I'm good.
I'm not rolling with you.
Because
their ego is in check and they realize that's not going to get him anywhere.
Yeah.
Rolling with this big idiot.
There's not going to get him anywhere.
So they're saying,
no,
I don't want to run with you.
Their Egos,
fine.
They get their over it.
So put your ego in check.
You won't get marked up a lot and people,
people will go full speed.
If you're going full speed,
that's the answer.
The harder you go,
the harder the other person's going.
You don't want to go in there and get to a level seven death match with every
person you roll with,
you're going to get them.
You're going to get them,
especially with people that are around your level.
Yeah.
Because if the person's a purple belt or a brown belt or a black belt,
you can go nuts on them.
It doesn't even matter to them.
They're just going to be laughing at you.
Although you can,
you can offend them.
And I've seen some black belts and some good Jujitsu,
Jujitsu practitioners that get offended if someone attacks them with fury,
like they have a chance and you go,
okay,
cool.
You want to be like that,
I'm going to smash you.
And I've done that from time to time.
You know where someone just there,
they're in there,
they're like,
they think it's their day or whatever and they think they're going to get you
and you go,
oh,
you're not going to get me,
but now you've,
now you're going to get God and is not going to be fun.
Yeah.
That tends to happen though.
Not if you're well within the confines of just Jujitsu stuff like,
um,
but if you start to drift towards the edges of etiquette,
so like let's say like if,
if it,
you know,
I'm going to spar with you in today's my day and I start stiff arming you hard
and doing that kind of stuff.
Stuff that's,
it's legal,
but it's like,
yeah,
for sure you shouldn't,
you know,
it's like that kind of stuff that'll make a higher belt med,
I think when you are correct,
you are correct.
It just someone going,
just someone going level nine psycho.
Yeah.
Instead of just being,
oh you want to roll,
hey,
cool.
You,
hey,
we're going to use strength.
I get that.
I get that we're going to use strength.
That's the way it works.
That's part of the game.
That's why we work out.
Right.
I get that.
We're going to go fast.
That's cool.
But you want to just go level nine psycho.
Cool.
That's not going to work out good.
Yeah.
And just cruise man.
Have a good time.
Yeah.
Nothing wrong with that.
I'm a huge advocate of cruising for sure.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm,
I support like guys going heart for sure.
Even like young guys,
I mean like with where this guy,
but,
but the thing is this guy is saying how does he stop it?
Yeah.
The way you stop it is by relaxing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I'm full supportive people going hard,
you know,
and I go hard.
Right.
I go,
I guess you're right.
Yeah.
I mean I trained hard for sure,
but um,
like if I don't know you yeah.
And you want to just go level nine,
cool.
We'll go level mine.
But you know,
yeah,
it's all,
it's all the spectrum of,
of Jujitsu.
And also I get it though,
like,
you know,
he doesn't want marks all over his face all the time for,
I mean to me you don't even have to say because of work,
you can just say,
I don't want marks.
I live with my neck and my face all the time,
you know,
cause that's actually what I do.
It's cool.
But you know how like,
okay,
so I don't wear mouthpieces anymore.
So every once in a great while,
like I'll
bite my tongue and then you can't eat for a few days.
Not that good.
Yeah,
it's a,
or you ever get your job,
you can't eat,
just know it's hurts.
The next question is valid with Italian dressing.
Really.
You're right,
you're right.
Eat for a club.
That's exaggerating,
but,
or if you get like a jaw,
like this is what I'll get,
my common one,
you'll get your job whacked my knee or something.
Opposite dental.
Soccer.
Yeah.
So you can't bite down on that side.
So you kind of can't eat for like a week.
You gotta chew you gotta you gotta drink through a straw anyway.
Um,
but so yeah,
I get it.
But just like how you said,
man,
it's that ego and I'm in support of ego.
If for kind of what gives you Jujitsu and doing Jujitsu,
it's luster.
Really.
The guy like a guy going like,
what if I wrote with you and I tap you out,
but you were not going hard at all.
I don't want to do that.
I'd rather get tapped out by you every single time.
Then tap you out when you weren't going hard as far as like my Jujitsu journey
kind of thing.
Yeah.
But,
but at the same time,
like,
Bro,
if you don't want that beef,
if you don't want to go with some big guy going hard bread,
just say sorry bro.
I mean,
no districts,
the main concern is not disrespecting the guy.
Like,
you know how you,
I've asked people to roll and I know I'm maybe a little bit more bigger,
whatever,
and then like the average guy,
so we'll ask someone to roll and they,
they won't even answer,
they'll just look away,
straight up,
look away.
And I'm like,
okay,
I really got to kind of understand,
maybe they just don't want that beef and they don't know how to say it to me
respectfully.
You know?
I've never had anyone like look away.
That's weird.
Yeah.
I had a time you asked them.
I okay.
I asked a guy to roll and he acted like he didn't hear me and looked away.
I went to the next guy of standing up to maybe that kind of helped,
didn't help my situation,
but whatever.
Um,
I asked the guy right next to him,
same exact thing.
He acted like,
oh he was kind of in a conversation and then I'll let me,
I've got little bit frustrated.
I said,
so no one wanted,
no one's rolling here.
That's what I said.
So that's what we're doing.
Everyone's seen that unknown is wrong and then like someone rolls up to me to
think whatever his little while ago,
but the intimidated,
but here's the thing is a thing.
Of course at the time it's a little bit frustrating and this is kind of part of
the point where if they didn't want to roll cause maybe whatever else too big
and they were like small or something like that,
then you can tell the guy,
hey respectfully like I don't want to roll with you.
I fear injury,
I fear whatever.
If your marks on my face or whatever,
no problem.
I dig it and I understand even if there's no one else,
the role where you're saying have the respect to tell you the truth.
That's the thing that needs the little pump of like they're scared of you.
He doesn't be the opposite though.
Nonetheless.
That's,
that's the thing though.
Like you,
that's what you have to,
in my opinion,
you have to address it
because I may have the,
that
being said,
like if someone wants to roll with you,
if you're a healthy human being,
man,
getting on.
That's,
you know what I'm saying?
That's what I was saying.
I get it.
If you have a situation,
and this is one that I need to,
I always have to watch out for.
Like if I have,
let's say I'm injured and let's say I normally do 10 rounds,
nine rounds,
eight rounds,
like that's my normal training and when I'm injured I'll be like,
okay,
I'm only going to do like four rounds.
We're going to do five rounds.
But then someone's like,
let's get one more.
Yeah.
And that's the hardest thing for me is to say no because my instinct all the
time is like,
oh,
if someone wants to roll,
let's do it.
Let's do it.
You just get it on.
You want to roll with me?
Let's get it on.
Yeah.
And so
yeah,
again,
this is all part of it too.
And this is a total opinion or philosophy or whatever.
But yeah,
that's how it should be.
That's what I think do,
You know,
like if I asked you to roll and you're just sitting there during the rolling
part of,
of training and you're just sitting there essentially waiting for someone to
asks you to roll.
Really?
That's what it is.
Right?
You know,
and you'd like turn your head then why are you here?
Like you're only going to roll with,
you asked me to roll and I was like,
hey man,
I got to tweak me.
I can't roll anymore today.
Metal,
you're going with that.
Fine.
Yeah,
100% you go home and then I got jacked.
That up isn't winning.
It's chocolate.
I would do 100% but yes,
no,
I'm talking about being selective with who you roll.
Like I won't roll with him because he'll tap me out.
I won't roll with him because he goes,
he goes hard and I'll get tired.
Toughest people.
Yeah.
Okay.
And again,
that's like your philosophy.
And I agree with that.
But if you're like being selective,
like that guy is too big and advanced,
he might mess me up.
Look,
if you're,
if you're concerned about actual injury,
that's one thing.
But if you're like,
like the,
basically the situation that I explained those in and this is what,
this is what I think given all the,
all the information I kind of gathered from the situation.
They didn't want to roll with me because I was maybe,
I dunno,
big or intimidating where you higher belts than them.
Yes.
That's really weird then.
No,
but see and that's what I thought too.
I was like,
well maybe there's honestly here bell,
if you're a lower belt and you're smaller,
you have absolutely nothing.
No shame in getting tapped out by a big dude.
That's a higher belt.
The new,
that's what I was saying,
cause I was talking to my brother and DJ.
Did you do a breath check before you went in there or something?
Maybe a d check.
Maybe you just smelled really bad.
No one wanted to roll with you and Oprah because of the fact is I did do those
checks.
I do them every single time.
That's why I know.
But I talked to my brother and Greg about this.
I was like,
I was trying to be understanding,
you know,
but at the first part of the conversation,
uh,
no,
I don't think Greg was there.
You might,
you might,
you might underestimate Greg train.
You might be like,
oh,
I'll just roll with this little guy.
You see his ears here.
Like
I was talking to them like the next day or something.
So they weren't there.
But,
um,
so Greg was saying the same thing as used like,
Nah,
you don't do that stuff.
Why are you even here that you know,
but Jay brought up a good point.
He said,
well,
it doesn't matter why you think they should be there.
They're there.
They pay their membership and they're there to learn Jujitsu.
They have the right to train with whoever they want and they have the right to
not train with whoever.
They don't want to change with the freewill.
It's true and that,
but that,
that very thing applies to this guy right here.
Etiquette out the window.
Jay Charles,
right?
Yeah.
And that's kind of the counter argument,
which is legitimate by the way.
There is the etiquette of the mats.
It's like,
it's like if you go to a 24 hour fitness gym or whatever,
you're the guy,
you're not,
I mean now nowadays they have a sign says rewrite your weights.
But you know,
there's certain things that you just,
you just got to do for the etiquette.
You don't have to walk far.
Yeah,
of course.
Came up again.
Akbar.
Yeah,
he's a beast and he fights at one 55 so we'd walk around at one 70 strong and
not scared,
but you know,
he and I would have wars,
wars,
total wars,
every single time mayhem.
And we had a packed always is,
I will roll with you no matter what.
No matter what is going on,
I will,
I will with it.
And it was always like he'd come in for,
for me it was,
you know,
I'd roll in from either work or I'd be done training with a bunch of people and
then he'd show up.
Or for him it was,
he'd be done with like a crazy sparring session.
But yeah,
so I was,
I always told them no matter what,
I'll roll with you because,
and the reason I told them that is because I didn't want to roll with him.
Yeah.
Because it was always freaking hardcore.
It was always,
because he moved all the time and he was so strong and so fast and boney and
he's submissions are savage and he was a guy I'd like,
I didn't want to roll with them and that's exactly why I made a pact with my,
I would always roll with it.
Do it.
You want to be.
Yeah.
Cause it is a,
it's a siege to roll with it.
And there's guys like that and you don't like,
you know,
it's funny,
you know Taylor and Andy by the way,
there like that if you make it like that,
but if you don't,
well you might be different cause you're kind of in a different position.
But when you wrote with them,
if you start to go light,
they'll just go light the whole time by the way.
But if you turn up the heat then they'll turn up the heat.
But yeah,
that's,
that's a big thing where like some guys man and you're like,
okay,
I've got to get mentally ready to do this.
You know,
because they just bring a lot and depends how your game matches up with them.
Yeah.
You know,
you're gay matches differently with different people.
Yeah,
that's true too.
Big 10 but yeah,
this guy,
you know,
does it normally leave you with lots of marks?
Not really.
I think you're right.
And,
but the more,
the more,
you know,
ambitious,
hungry,
a white belts you row with the e.
Yeah.
The more and March.
And the more and more your ego forces you to fight them as if it's a death match
level nine.
Yeah.
Very true.
And then do people who go full speed?
You know what,
50 50 maybe?
Well No,
technically no awful.
It's like can you cruise like I always do a warm up one warm up round with Andy.
No one else with Andy and Dean Dean won't do a warm up around with me cause
that's when he really taxed at full strength deet.
Andy is awesome and we always do one round just to break a sweat.
We're just cruising and then the next one we'll go,
all right when we go,
I mean we go,
I guess maybe there's some gradation at the high end of the spectrum and I will
recognize a difference between that.
Like let's say for instance you say like,
I'll know I don't want to let any pass my guard today.
Right.
It was like for referred like a legit reason.
Like I think he's got some new office and move that I've seen been pulling off
and I go,
what if he gets his position on me today?
I'm going to be in a real bad situation so he's not passing my card.
So then he'll feel like I'm going harder.
Yeah,
because a lot of times you were younger,
you pass my guard.
Okay,
cool.
Whatever.
And now you're across side.
Now they're trying to escape that.
What are,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
that's like when you're competing,
we are,
when you're,
when someone is competing with you in Jujitsu,
especially with the gay,
it's so noticeable in a competition how hard they grip everything and how you
can't get a millimeter of movement that you don't have to fight for.
You can't simulate that in,
you can't simulate that level of intensity on the mats that only comes to
competition.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The,
in the chart on the training maths.
But in a way,
and I talked to Greg about this a lot where it's kind of,
you know how like someone's being super stubborn,
like what the day I was talking to him,
this is what I was talking about.
Like the guy who you get a sweep autumn or something and they don't,
it's almost like they're not even fighting Jujitsu anymore.
They just want to get to their feet and stand up cause they don't want to play
on the bottom right.
These guys.
So I'll talk to them that him about that and you know that it was kind of
frustrating and whatever and he was like,
hey bro,
like that's like that's kind of his job was to like give you an accurate
representation of somebody giving you trouble in whatever way I was about to
tell it.
That's the same thing that Jade Charles says.
Like if that guy,
if you allow that guy to get to your feet,
then that's bad.
As a matter of fact,
I went through this cycle with Dean where I realized that I wasn't giving dean a
good representation because every time he had some good guard passes that he
would do from a little bit of a distance and,
and they were working well.
And then I said,
well,
why don't I just stand up?
Yeah.
And so then I just started standing up and then all of a sudden he realized he
couldn't give me that much space,
which messed up that guard pass,
which put us back to both getting better because we are improving the,
the techniques that we were each using.
So yeah,
sometimes.
Now,
have you ever rolled with someone that you,
um,
they're just not doing,
they're there.
They are.
They're just,
they're just not engaging.
They're not engaged.
And that can be,
that can be a little bit frustrating.
Yes.
And sometimes I do that.
Yeah.
But that's part of an overall strategy as part of the launch strategy.
But yeah.
Oh yeah,
100%.
Like the guy,
the guy who is not because,
and again,
this goes back to why you're doing Jujitsu to begin
with though.
So let's say if you,
if you're doing it,
like to compete in a tournament,
a guy not engaging,
that's part of your training right there too.
If you're like,
you know,
if this is the fight in,
if you like all elements and let's say you're focusing on like a self defense
situation and the guy's not engaging,
then yeah,
you might as well be like I am.
I might as well train with those.
Good.
You're right.
It is good.
Because also I've gone with like some wrestlers that they know,
they're,
let's say there are purple belt in Jujitsu and they're doing a five minute round
with you and they're just there.
They're goal is to just avoid and knock it tapped out.
And they're not really gonna Roll Jiu Jitsu with you.
They're just going to avoid and knock a tapped out.
You're not going to progress like,
oh,
they get the double leg now they're in your guard.
They're gonna sit there and hold your hips.
Yeah.
So they're gonna sit there.
So for me,
what I have to do,
I need to have some moves.
It gets them out of the,
that's you got to take some ownership for though.
Yeah.
Just like the guy who doesn't like task,
who strong,
it doesn't tap,
you know?
So either forces you to like in Jerome or let go kind of thing.
That's kind of the same thing where it's,
it's,
it's a weird dichotomy though because like,
what do you do now?
Now it's Kinda up to you.
You know the guy who,
okay,
so if a guy doesn't tap right and you kind of get mad,
I'm look good,
you're going to force me to injure you.
You know,
you have to take that training as,
as this realistic training where this guy is giving you a very accurate look,
where sure you can choose to enjoy them.
Now it's on you.
You chose to intro.
Sure.
And whatever you chose,
you chose,
especially if he was giving you less of an option or you just let them go and
understand that.
Yeah,
I understand accurately gotta be honest with yourself that I would've had that
submission.
I could have been dumb,
but don't be all mad because you shop dept and give me that Wayne in training,
you know,
like,
don't do that,
you know?
Yeah.
You gotta you gotta keep your mind wait,
but you said who cares?
Come on Bro.
Come on.
All right,
so your,
you were talking but I know,
but you care though.
I care.
What if someone,
if someone,
cause one time I,
the reason I was talking to,
well I was talking to Greg again about it,
about,
I'm a guy was walking with who didn't want to tap and I was mad because he was
forcing me to either in his room or he wasn't going to give me that,
that win in training.
So what'd you do?
I let them go from one time and it was a white belt.
He started going hard.
You know how this is just an old wine belt.
What submission was it?
I'm talking about another story now.
I told them,
I'm just saying like Maura,
the both.
Okay.
So the,
the regional story.
I was talking that's all comedian not tap into a community.
Yeah,
he was strong.
But um,
so maybe you didn't really have it like I had it.
It's,
I'm not weak either.
That's the thing.
So He's strong and I'm like,
okay.
It's to hear your steer.
It's here.
It didn't matter.
I knew,
I knew with certainty where it's like,
okay,
I'm going to have to injure the person now.
Um,
and you know,
he didn't have,
but Greg made a good point where it's like,
that's his job.
You know,
he's giving you an accurate look of what it's like.
So at the end of the day,
sure I could have chose to insure them and then it's partially his fault.
But the thing is I can't account for whether it's his fault or not.
I'm accounting for what training I'm getting,
by the way.
What training?
I'm getting not come,
you know,
it's not a competition.
It's not in the street.
Switching stories.
I'll make it quick too.
It was a white belt that was rolling with,
he was going nuts and I took it personal back to what we were talking about you
at this time,
purple.
So I was taking it personal.
It's like,
well,
what do or you try to go nuts on me.
Like just doing stuff.
It was all within the confines of etiquette,
but he was going a little bit too hard.
Right.
Later I find out that's just his style by the way,
which is a total innocent thing.
But at that time I was like,
no.
I was like,
okay,
you want to go hard,
I'm going to go hard.
And I injured them.
Here's the thing,
I injured him with a submission cause I went d Kimora again.
And not that I did it necessarily so hard that I heard him,
but he had a bad shoulder and I didn't really know.
He said no,
no,
it's okay.
I had a bad shoulder.
I was gonna say,
I've never injured anyone with a submission,
but I have injured a couple people.
One of them Diandra you.
Yeah,
my red man.
I injured myself.
Yeah,
no,
but I'm saying with a submission locked in,
right?
Yeah.
The Times I've done it is I can only think of one off the top of my head.
And it was a guy,
like you said,
just had preexisting shoulder injury that was like,
that was like,
ah,
tap and then I'm hurt and then my shoulders bad.
Right Bro,
you're rolling with me.
Tell me.
It was a black belt,
you know,
it was like,
Bro,
come on.
I'm not a guy.
I'd seen her in awhile.
I just go,
you know,
big,
strong guy.
God got the career and I'd put it on and all of a sudden he's like,
ah,
and injured and,
and I just said,
Bro,
I didn't,
it wasn't,
I mean I know the complete limitations of where it's injury or not and I was not
there yet at all.
Yeah.
And so he's like,
Yo,
I got a bad shoulder.
I should have told you.
Yeah.
And that's actually why I felt really guilty because I did.
I was like,
Oh,
you want to go hard?
Until I did it hard,
I wasn't trying to hurt him.
But if you had a bad shoulder,
which he did,
I understand it hurt him and I,
that doesn't surprise me that it hurt them and I shouldn't,
I shouldn't have went that heart to begin with as far as like going,
I know how to do.
He Kimora good.
Yeah.
And just kind of to clarify my earlier statements,
like when somebody goes level nine on me,
it doesn't mean I'm like Alto.
No,
I just go,
I just apply level.
If they're a little mind,
I'm gonna apply a level 9.1 back to them and put them and actually usually I do
something to him that forces them to calm down.
Like I'll just,
I'll get across side and be like,
hm.
Keeps spousing keep going.
Nuts.
Right now I'm just going to be here.
We're cruising
at level 9.1 but just the level of nine for one book,
completely cruising because they can't move.
They're there talking and going crazy and getting nuts and then you're just
sitting there.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I still feel guilty about that day.
I'll never do it again.
Next question.
Hi Jocko.
I have read your book extreme ownership from cover to cover it and I learned a
lot from it and I have a question that bothers me.
The question is how can I be noticed by the people and get chosen for a leader?
Okay,
good.
Kind of uh,
another question that I hear,
you know,
people get worried that if they're just kind of putting their head down and
working,
then they were not going to get noticed.
How do I get noticed how I become a leader?
Stop worrying about being noticed that that's number one,
stop worrying about being noticed and keep working hard.
Stop warning about being chosen as a leader.
If your goal is to get chosen as a leader,
no work hard.
I actually work really hard and then put the team first.
So all these thoughts and efforts that you have around getting noticed and being
recognized instead of having them focused on being recognized and being noticed,
put those thoughts on making the team successful.
Wow.
Put the team first.
That's what I'm saying right now with this question,
you're actually putting yourself your self recognition above the team.
So instead of thinking about that,
think about how you can help the team win.
And the more of a team player you are,
the more people will want to work with you.
The more you help the team win,
the more people say,
I want you on my team.
And eventually they say,
okay,
you know what?
I want you to lead this team because you want this team to win so bad.
We want you to lead this team.
So that is what you do.
Now that being said,
right,
there's always,
there's always a balance because I'm not saying that you sit back and just keep
your fingers crossed that if you work hard,
someone's going to notice you.
Now with this guy who's all worried about being noticed,
don't worry about being noticed.
You're going to get noticed if you work out and put your head down.
But there's some people that they're there,
so they might be so humble that they're not going to get noticed for what
they're doing.
So how do you overcome that?
Well,
this doesn't mean that you sit back in your past.
If there's an oh and I'll tell you the best way to stand out or one of the best
ways to stand out is volunteer,
volunteer for everything that comes up and then crush it.
The crappy jobs that no one wants.
Volunteer for those things.
That's what I used to see.
You should see the,
the young new guys in the seal teams,
that's how you tell you get some crappy job.
You walk out to a,
a group of guys going through training through it.
A bunch of platoon guys,
you're,
hey,
I need three guys.
There'd be like two new guys that would just be like by their hands would be up
before you could get done saying the sentence and you just see the look on their
face.
What do they want to do?
They just want to win.
I use,
I love those guys.
They're just like,
oh,
I'll do that.
Hey,
hey,
I need a couple of guys through.
Boom.
They're hands are up.
You don't even know,
you know,
gun to say,
go clean the sewer out.
They don't care.
They're volunteering for everything and you know what?
I got when I got to the team.
That's what I did.
Volunteered for every,
as a matter of fact,
I volunteered to be a radio man because I'd heard that it was a really hard job
that no one wanted it.
It was like,
oh,
okay,
I'll do that job.
You got a job that's really hard.
No one wants to carry a heavy weight.
You don't get to shoot it.
Right.
You get to carry them 60 there a major benefit to that.
That is you get to unload massive amounts of firepower.
You carry your radio,
you're just sitting around with batteries.
It's kind of hardcore in a different way.
It is.
And I,
luckily I got,
I got told two things,
number one,
that no one wanted that job.
And number two,
that if you were radium and you'd go on every mission because they always need a
radio man,
and that's all help me a lot.
To me,
I want to go on every mission,
so I'll take,
I'll carry that radio,
but that,
that and everything,
you know,
you use a volunteer for everything.
So that's,
that's one of the best ways that you can make a good impression is by
volunteering for stuff and then crushing it.
And eventually people look at you and they say,
Oh,
this guy doesn't care what we give them.
He's going to crush this task.
And you know what?
People like working with him because he's worried about the team and this person
seems like a,
let's get him,
let's give him a little task then and lead something.
Because sometimes when you volunteer for something,
you're volunteering for leadership position.
Hey,
I need four guys,
one of those people,
it's going to be in charge.
Right.
For,
it's not gonna be four guys going equally into some thing,
right?
No.
Someone's going to be within charge.
Yeah.
Someone's going to take charge of it.
Be that person.
Yeah.
Huh.
That's good.
This,
um,
when he said,
how can I be noticed?
So work hard.
Yeah.
But you know how it's like,
okay,
that's,
that's what I want.
I want to be noticed.
Right.
So you ever walk into a bar or something and a girl walks in and she,
you can tell she's trying to be noticed if the bad luck,
man,
so what I'm saying is you like if you're trying to be noticed so people can see
that stuff like is kind of just trying to be noticed right here and it does the
opposite obviously.
That's,
yeah,
you're right.
That's the hardest thing to convince the people,
convince people love is the fact that if you're just,
if you're just working hard,
you'll get noticed.
You will get noticed.
It's like you do something kind of good or whatever.
Brave.
I don't know.
Hey,
look,
did you guys all see how brave I was right there?
Yeah.
Brad,
no one wants you to be a leader.
All right there.
It's like saying,
Hey,
I'm like,
hey guys,
that task I did pretty good,
right?
I was really humble.
No one's,
no one's more humble than me.
No one's La homeless.
Stop worrying about you and think of helping the team and volunteer a bunch of
nuts.
That's where you'll end up in a leadership position.
Got time for one more.
Yeah,
might as well.
Last question.
Question for Uncle Jake from James,
who's nine,
can you be but strong
at the same time?
Can you be weak but strong at the same time?
Yes you can.
You can't because you can be,
for instance,
you can be physically strong,
but at the same time you could be mentally weak or you could be the opposite.
You could be mentally weak,
but at the same time physically strong.
And I would love to be able to put a priority on one of those.
And I know I've said before that knowledge is the most important thing,
but the reality is if you don't have the strength or actually the health
to back that up,
or even to function as a human being physically,
then your knowledge and your mental strength doesn't really even matter.
So that comes into play.
And being big and strong is also totally useless.
If you're mentally weak and you quit.
Now being mentally strong should actually lead you to being physically strong.
Because if you are mentally strong,
then you can work and train to become physically strong.
But if you're
mentally weak,
then you will not hold the line on the good foods and the good workouts and you
won't get physically strong or healthy.
So
can you be weak and strong at the same time?
Yes,
but I say be strong.
Train your physical strength and exercise your mental strength by doing the
right things via hard things.
Okay.
The things you know you're supposed to do,
do them
and be as strong as you can mentally,
physically,
and emotionally for yourself,
for your team,
for your family.
Hold the line
and be strong.
Okay.
And I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles,
speaking of holding the line,
perhaps you could hold your portion of the line here and explained to people how
they can support this podcast in the event
that they would like to do so sure.
Be Happy to.
Thanks for allowing me the opportunity.
We'll talk about origin,
right?
American made course from the beginning to end.
American made.
It's a big deal actually.
Also supplements,
right?
Jocko supplements.
Wait,
American made what?
What was that first part?
Everything.
I'm just saying that's like a disclaimer.
Like everything we're about to talk about from origin is American made straight
up.
So people,
you've been being asked about supplements for a while.
Yeah,
probably from the beginning I think.
All right,
well here you go.
Here's some Jocko supplements for your joints.
Krill oil,
Super Krill oil.
So not just cries,
Super Krill oil,
Jocko,
Super Krill oil.
Boom.
Also Jocko joint warfare.
That's like a blend.
Glucosomine couldn't joy is it [inaudible] can Jordan can in which comes from,
you know where it comes from?
Sea Cucumbers.
Didn't know that.
Did you,
ah,
I'd actually,
I think you'd mentioned it,
but I don't,
you know,
hey,
we know now and really that's what's important.
Um,
very good stuff because I would say it is the main thing,
like joint supplements,
like Krill oil,
you know,
the,
these are,
these supplements helped me way more than any protein powder.
And back in the,
I used to take protein powder and you know,
these weight gainer things and I don't even think that they helped really.
I'm not saying they don't help,
but I just,
you just don't.
These,
the joint stuff,
Krill oil,
especially joint warfare.
These things help you way more and for a longer too,
by the way.
Nonetheless,
there's also some geese on there and rash guards still all made in America
from the beginning to the end.
It's one thing to import material from,
you know,
other places,
and that's cool too.
I get it and I dig it,
but in the event of you wanting it,
uh,
you know all this stuff they'd be made made in America.
Boom.
Origin main.com.
Go on there,
see what you like,
get something if you want.
Also fitness gear.
So I was,
you know,
I'm into kettle bells now I'm into other lifting too of course.
But kettlebells are a bigger part of my routine and just slowly I kind of get
more like,
oh you get stronger,
you get the bigger one.
I took a step back the other day when I was lifting,
stood back and looked at my setup.
It's pretty dope.
I don't have like the normal kettle bells.
It's like I have this one.
The point is k so on it,
that's where I get the kettle bells from on it.
You got some other cool stuff on there,
but minor,
all the primal bells.
One few legend bells.
They're like the artistic ones obviously kind of when you sit back and you look,
look at your set up,
I think that's a big deal when you're set up is dope.
I'm just saying.
Yeah,
you want your set up to be dealt,
going to audit,
get their kettle bells.
You can get the regular ones to see that and they're kind of understated and I
dig it.
But um,
and I'm sticking with the Werewolf.
I got that big foot one 90 pounds.
I've been doing some work with dawn.
How big is yours?
My biggest is 40 kilograms.
That's only 88 cents.
There might be getting two pounds stronger than me.
Yeah,
every single rep.
So that's,
that's something cool.
It's not nothing.
It's something.
Anyway,
[inaudible] dot com slash Jocko that's a good one.
Same thing.
Go on there.
You like something,
get something good way to support.
Also when you buy these books,
the Jocko reviews from time to time,
no book today.
I understand,
but you want to buy any of those books on our website,
Jocko,
podcast.com section called books from episodes,
all the books by episode.
Boom.
Click through there and when you get them
and if you happen to do any other shopping,
boom,
click through their same thing,
same deal,
you know,
goes and takes you to Amazon and you know,
boom.
That's a good way to support small action.
Big Retail.
You know,
just the one little click go in their shop.
Boom.
Good way to support.
Excellent way to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already.
Seems obvious.
I know,
but you know,
sometimes you want to listen to one or two or whatever.
Be like,
is it worth it to subscribe I think,
I think,
yeah.
Subscribed.
You think so?
Yeah.
I subscribed to this podcast to me too and I,
I have the actual,
yeah,
might as well.
It's good and that's a good way to support leave a review if you're in the mood
to cause,
I mean it makes sense.
You know where you figure,
you know,
people on Twitter,
they'll say like if something's up like hey you,
you know you,
there was like,
like a definition.
Remember the,
there was the one book I,
it's,
I'm drawing a blank on which book,
but it was a British one was a mistake.
No,
there wasn't a mistake.
There was the word knob number.
You called them and I was like,
what does the Knob,
and then people on Twitter were like,
boom,
send it to me.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
So it makes sense,
you know,
feedback man.
Pete,
we're all involved,
you know.
So yeah,
if you want to leave a review,
leave a review.
If you're in the mood,
don't have to of course.
But if you're in the mood to also youtube,
subscribe to the Allen.
We have a youtube channel,
Jocko podcasts.
Pretty good one.
On top of the video version of this podcast,
we include little excerpts from the podcast.
Just little nuggets of,
you know how,
especially with the Q and a,
it's,
it's good because it's like,
okay,
I don't want listen to the whole Q and a.
Even though I do mark them by timestamp in subject,
but nonetheless,
you know their little note where you can kind of share it with,
oh shoot,
I remember my friend who needed some advice on you did two rolling or how to do
good in college or whatever,
you know,
so you can just share it with them.
They don't have to listen to the whole podcast anyway.
They're little excerpts we put on there.
Some other stuff do deleted scenes from time to time.
Wait,
add another one of those.
Anyway,
point is subscribe to our youtube channel if you want to.
Also Jack was a store.
It's called Jocko store.
Jacqueline,
store.com on there.
There are t shirts,
travel mugs,
some bumper stickers.
We might be out of bumper stickers.
No,
no,
no.
We are both bumper stickers,
some women's stuff on there.
Some shirts of course with La.
I feel like we haven't talked about the layers on the shirts recently.
That's really disappointing to everyone.
Or maybe are you talk about the layers on or maybe that in and of itself is a
layer,
right?
You just don't talk about the layers.
You just let them exist.
Layers.
That's a layer in its own right.
That's what I mean there.
Yeah,
exactly right.
So it is pretty lame if you have described the layers.
Yeah.
It's like describing like the punchline of a joke kind of.
It's not a Joni.
Yeah.
It's just the lack jail.
Either way.
Just some shirts on there.
Also rash guards,
I think we're doing a warrior kid rash guard.
Oh Nice.
We're doing it with Pete.
Oh,
nice American made or your kid rash guards.
Nice.
One side says when other sites has learned in the back says this is about
everything day going to be good credit.
How far out of the of those from being released.
Oh,
we're narrowing down the cut.
You know,
because I'm tough talking to Pete.
He's like,
kids are shaped different.
There's just shaped kind of weird.
So you got to,
there's some refining that kind of has to go into the shape.
But yeah,
that's more or less it also some,
I said women's stuff,
but yeah,
some hoodies,
hoodies should be,
should be available.
Nice.
Not right this moment.
Anytime of this moment.
They're common.
Yeah.
Thick winter hoodies either way.
And if you go on there,
and if this,
if something's out,
which risk,
especially now like I'm trying,
I'm really narrowing down my whole process there.
But if something's out of stock or whatever,
there's a little thing on there and you just put your email in there.
I don't,
it's not a spam thing at all.
In fact,
a lot of people who sign up for email list,
which is another thing,
like I don't really send much the point,
and not that that's a good thing,
but I'm saying no.
Sometimes I get contacted by these people
with their advice,
advice about stuff.
And I'm not,
not trying to say,
I'm like,
I'm not being arrogant.
Right.
But they're the people that talk to me about like,
um,
oh,
what is it?
Building the,
Oh,
the,
okay.
About the podcasts.
Like the brands,
like you should do more social media.
No,
they say,
uh,
you know,
don't,
one of the most valuable things you could do is get an email list and you get a
big email list and you can hammer my stuff all the time,
Andy and you have them forever.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
Bro,
I'm,
I'm not,
we're not here to just like a hammer people with whatever messaging.
Yeah.
So yeah,
you can sign up for it.
The email list that you made,
I mean,
what I put out like one thing or maybe two things on it,
you put out maybe two things or three things where you do one thing that you do
that's good as you give him,
this is the,
this is where it's beneficial.
If you want something you'll find out about it earlier,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yes.
And also you've let the youth,
you've done some uh,
polling like,
Hey,
what color of this shoe we make.
So,
and that's really what it is.
It's more like a direct line.
Like for people who like,
like I care,
like if a new item comes out,
item,
there's something new on the story comes out or something,
something super relevant,
like I'm not going to be like,
Hey,
by the way,
let me just send you this that you won't read or I dunno.
Like I won't just,
I don't use it to,
I don't think it should be used ever,
but,
so I don't use it to try to like keep your attention on my website.
You know,
it's not that I figure if I looked at it kinda like,
I don't know,
I forget if I heard someone say this or not,
but it was really,
it really made sense where you know,
when you sign up for an email list,
right?
So a marketer,
a quote unquote marketer,
we'll look at that and be like,
okay,
they just signed it,
signed up to be marketed to.
Right.
So every time I enter in my email for like,
do you want updates?
You know how they give you my email for those things.
Just kind of part of the point because you know I'm signing signing up right now
to see marketing marketed to,
so people are gonna sign up.
They say,
okay,
I want to be marketed to.
I'm not going to like a beauty.
It's like I'm not going to instantly violate your check mailed to people if I
just figure if you truly believe that,
like that's what they signed up for.
They don't know what I'm saying.
Should I send out like an email of information or something?
Yeah,
yeah.
So yeah,
exactly.
Yes.
So that's what I should do.
If if you think,
okay,
so think of me as like a person who's like,
hey yeah,
I'll sign up for this email in this aisle.
And so I put my email in there and then so now you're contemplation.
I sent them an email.
If you think that that,
that email legitimately is what I want to get from you when I put my email,
then yes,
and then you go,
I don't even know what that is.
So that's why I hardly say anything.
I just figured,
Hey,
if there's a new rash guard when,
especially when people on Twitter or Instagram,
whatever,
telling me,
hey do this for a rash guard or hey do this for a shirt or wear the hats coming
out when the Hoodie,
you know,
when's the Hoodie?
I've been waiting for the kids size small.
So for instance is a good one.
You will email when the,
when the new hoodies are available.
When you email everyone.
Yeah.
And actually I did one better where I don't even have to email everybody because
what if people are like,
I already have a Hoodie so,
and yet they're on the list so I'll do you one better on the Hoodie on the
store.
When you click on the Hoodie,
select a size and it's out.
You can just be like,
oh put your email right there.
You'll only get emailed if the Hoodie gets back in stock in your specific size.
Otherwise you don't get nothing.
I'm not going to bother your inbox.
Your inbox is sacred.
Okay.
Just cause you gave me the key.
It doesn't mean to show up everyday.
Okay.
So cool.
Like that.
Yeah,
I think,
I think that's the
way to go.
So marketers,
whoever's listening to this right now,
that's,
that's like cold.
You're just missing out on so much opportunity.
Don't violate people's,
yeah.
We're not going to violate people's trust for opportunity.
Good job.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
it's good chuckles.
store.com if you need to look a checkup,
check those things out.
You know,
if he liked something,
get something good way to support.
Also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
we all know what that is.
Should I even mention what it is?
You should might as the case people don't know.
All right.
It's an album,
not a song album,
not a rap album.
What is it?
Good.
It's an album with tracks,
Jocko tracks and these tracks,
what they are is obviously you listened to him audio tracks,
right?
I tunes Google,
play Amazon music anywhere where they sell mp3s.
So what they are is you,
you put it in when you're,
when you're trying to get it,
like you set a goal,
you're trying to get after it and you're having these moments of weakness,
diet,
workout.
Uh,
getting up,
staying discipline,
creative,
procrastination,
all this,
all these points of weakness that you can encounter.
There's a track for one of them.
Boom.
You listened to it and it's booked.
It's kind of like Jocko at your fingertips in a way where you saying
you're like,
hey,
chocolate.
Okay,
so I have this luxury.
I can call you up and be like,
hey,
you know,
tonight,
uh,
I had uh,
I dunno,
stressful day and I still got some work to do.
I'm thinking of going to Vons and getting some vodka I don't want tomorrow.
I don't want to look back and be like,
I wish I wouldn't have drank vodka.
But right now I really want to go get that fat guy.
And it's very powerful and I think he'd do me some good,
really.
Some stuff I have the luxury of being able to call you up and be like,
hey,
boom.
And then you can just tell me,
explain to me pragmatically,
why shouldn't I do that?
I'll pretty thanks Jocko.
Boom.
I don't get the vodka.
A lot of people don't have that.
Get psychological warfare.
You do have that.
You just put in the track.
Boom.
You'll wake up early every single time.
If you're not feeling like waking up early,
you'll wake up.
Her same thing with worked out.
Same thing with procrastination,
all that stuff.
Anyway,
check them all out.
See if you like it.
Get one of those 100% effectiveness.
If you still slack after listening to this.
I said this before,
I'll say it again.
There's a problem.
I don't think you will.
So there is no problem.
There you go.
Oh,
that's a good one.
Good support.
Right on.
Uh,
also you can get Jocko white tea on Amazon.
Speaking of Amazon,
you can get Jocko white tea that you shouldn't drink it.
If you want a dead lift more than 7,000,
854 pounds,
cause that's what you will be able to do as soon as you drink your first sip to
guaranteed 100%.
Uh,
Jocko white tea tastes good and it makes you feel good and it's good for you.
So get that books.
I got some books.
One was called way of the warrior kid.
It's for kids.
But I think we can all learn from it.
I know I learned from it from good old uncle Jake got a book called extreme
ownership,
which is a book about leadership,
combat leadership lessons learned.
Also have a book called discipline equals freedom field manual just came out
October 17th I'm going to read you a little excerpt.
First excerpt coming from the,
and the reason I'm reading this is
a few weeks ago there was a mass shooting in Vegas.
Horrible situation and
ideal talk about all kinds of different things in this book about my life,
things I've learned and one of the things,
one of the sections in here is called immediate action drills.
Here we go back to the book,
but we can't always avoid high threat areas and sometimes the high threat area
doesn't avoid us in the world today,
conflict and danger can occur at anytime,
anywhere,
so it is important to maintain situational awareness at all times.
Pay attention to your surroundings,
look at suspicious people,
look at UNCC suspicious people.
What are they doing?
Where are they going?
What are they looking at?
Assess while you assess.
Think of contingencies.
Where is your closest escape route?
Where is the closest cover and concealment?
Cover being a place to shield you from bullets and concealment being a place to
hide.
If you are maintaining situational awareness,
you should be very hard to surprise.
If you send something is going wrong or you sense a threat,
proactively move away from it.
Walk to the other side of the street.
Accelerate your car,
walk out the door.
Don't wait for things to get worse.
If you do get surprised and are caught in a bad situation,
act.
If you can run away from an assailant,
do it.
If you can't run because they have a hold on,
you attack them.
Put all your training to use as quickly and as violently as possible.
As soon as you can break free,
do it and run.
Okay.
If shooting starts,
get down,
call the police at the first opportunity.
If the shooting is single shots being fired at a slower pace,
run immediately and keep running.
If the shooting is rapid fire,
find some solid cover to get behind.
Wait for a lull.
When the low comes run,
that may be your only chance.
If you are trapped in a room with an active shooter outside barricade yourself.
If there is no,
if there is an ideal hiding place,
hide if not prepared to attack them as soon as they enter the room.
Get anyone in the room with you on board and ready to swarm the attacker.
So those are some notes from where to start.
And again you can take training for those types of situations to a very high
degree.
But if you have no training,
you need to know what to do in those situations.
That's that's why I put that in there.
Um,
you know I will read this one more little section cause I to ask this all the
time,
I'll just do the beginning of the section dealing with injuries and illnesses.
What are you,
you are going to get injured.
You are going to get sick regardless of how careful you are in your training,
how clean you eat and how healthy you live,
you are still human injuries and illness will occur.
My theory for overcoming injuries and illness is simple.
Do what you can.
Okay.
If you are sick or injured,
don't use that as an excuse to skip workouts or stay in bed all day.
Do what you can.
Hurt your knee,
work your upper body,
work the good leg,
hurt your shoulder,
time to work on one arm to pull ups and push ups.
Focus on your core and legs until your shoulder heals up.
Tendinitis from using the grip.
Too much sound like it's time to focus on sprinting and jumping.
Plyometrics.
Got a little cold,
flu,
same thing.
Do what you can.
Maybe it's just going for a walk,
a couple sets of sit ups and pushups,
but don't just stay in bed all day.
So go on to talk about some more of that.
This book is called discipline equals freedom.
And
if you want to help spread the word on this,
um,
go in,
buy from a local bookstore like an independent bookstore.
Because when they sell these books,
they report it in such a way that it helps the book get recognized by some of
the bigger media outlets.
Okay?
And when it gets recognized by some of those big media outlets like the New York
Times or the Wall Street Journal that helps spread the word even more.
And I think that the word that's in this book should be spread because I think
it's gonna help a lot of people and I think it's gonna help them live better,
healthier and more productive lives.
So you can get that book discipline equals freedom field manual.
Yeah.
Also for your business,
we have actual on front leadership consulting to me Leif Babin,
JP didn't know Dave Burke.
If you need our services to help you,
your business,
your team,
your leadership,
give us an email info@echelonfront.com
and if you have questions or you have something you want to talk to us about
here,
you want to keep this little conversation going,
you can still find us always on the Inter webs
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Facebook.
Okay.
Echo is that Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally thank you to everyone for listening and supporting this podcast.
We truly appreciate it.
And for those of you in uniform,
thanks for providing the blanket of freedom that allows this podcast to be
possible and for the first responders that protect us at home that drive and run
towards danger.
Thank you for keeping us safe and to everyone else out there on your mission
to succeed,
to conquer,
to get better,
to win,
keep trading,
keep fighting,
keep working,
and striving and grinding to do more than anyone thought you could.
More than even you thought you could.
Okay.
Keep your eyes on the target,
your head in the game and keep on getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.